OKAY GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO THE PUBLIC RETIREMENT SO
SKIRTED COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE SEVENTEEN ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY.
FIRST FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FOUR BONTA AND
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTEEN GONZALEZ.
FLETCHER HAVE BEEN PULLED BY
THEM BY THE AUTHORS.
ALSO FAR ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX COOPER.
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB
TWENTY THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE
PURSE COMMITTEE ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
WILL TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SOON AS WELL QUORUM.
FINALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE A LONG
AGENDA TODAY AND OTHER
COMMITTEES OF WHERE ALSO. ALSO
COMMITTEES ARE MEETING WE'RE
GOING TO LIMIT TESTIMONY ON EACH
BILL TO TWO MINUTES. FOR TWO
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES ON EACH
SIDE.
EVERYONE AFTER THAT SIMPLY STATE
YOUR NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
AND THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WE
WILL START OF SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO WITH THAT SAID I BELIEVE WE
HAVE AN AUTHOR ARE READY.
SUCH SANTIAGO AND NO.
LARA I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN HERE
WAITING PATIENTLY SOAKING QUAN
UP FROM PRESENT.
TRADITIONALLY.
BUSH WHICH.
GOOD MORNING SOME REMEMBER
SEEING HER PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY ONE.
SO GO AHEAD WHEN WRITING.
IF WERE PREDECESSORS ESTABLISHED
UP IN THE POSITION OF COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVE TO ENHANCE THE
ABILITY OF SCHOOLS TO INTERACT
WITH BOTH THEIR STUDENTS AND THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. OVER THE
PAST FORTY SEVEN YEARS COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE PROVEN TO
BE ADEPT AT SERVING THEIR
SCHOOLS. AND WHAT'S WHAT'S
CONSIDERED A SHORT TERM SOLUTION
TO A MOMENT IN TIME HAS BECOME
AN INTEGRAL COMPONENT FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WANTING TO BETTER
CONNECT WITH STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
GOOD A LINK TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD
AND FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE THOSE WITH A
HIGHER NUMBER OF ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. THEY WORK TO
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS AND BARRIERS
AND IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS.
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE UPDATES
ARE EDUCATION COACH REFLECT
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES AS
PERMANENT CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT DISTRICTS NEED
TO STOP THE POSITIONS AS THEY
SEE FIT BY LIFTING THE CAP ON
THE NUMBER OF HOURS A
REPRESENTATIVE CAN WORK. THE
BILL SPONSORED BY S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OR.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION PROUD TO SUPPORT THE AND
SPONSOR THE SPELL AGUIAR PRESENT
IVES ARDEN TABLES A STAPLE TO
LAUSD ESPECIALLY FOR THEIR WHEN
THE KIDS GET OFF THE BUS WITH A
HOMEMADE HOT BREAKFAST NEAR
THERE JUST MAKE SURE THE KIDS
GET HOME SAFELY IN EVENING.
THE ISSUE MAY HAVE CHANGED OVER
FORTY YEARS THAT NEED STILL
THERE SO WE STRONGLY URGE I BOW
IN ALLOWING THESE MEMBERS
BETWEEN THE SAME AS OUR
COLLEAGUES AND PROPERLY
CLASSIFIED IN ALLOWED THE
DISTRICTS TO USE THEM AS MUCH AS
THEY DEEM THAT. LINK YOU.
BUT ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
BEARS JOSHUA LOCAL WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEN IN HERE OR I THINK WE HAVE
STE ONE MORE PERSON GOVERNOR FOR
SUPPORT. MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITH THAT SAID IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE.
SEARING IN HERE AT CNN HEARING
NONE BACK UP TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE.
THANK YOU OF ASSISTANCE FOR
STONE THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
BRING IT UP WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND WITHOUT THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I DO HAVE IRAQ ON THE
SPOT THANK YOU.
YEAH.
IT WITHOUT SAID WE HAVE ANOTHER
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR
CURRY HER PRESENT ON AB TWENTY
THREE TEN.
SO MEMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY GO
AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MEMBER.
AB TWENTY THREE TEN IS A
TECHNICAL DISTRICT BILL THAT
WILL MAKE A SMALL CHANGE IN
CALPERS AUTHORITY TO ALLOW THEM
TO IMPLEMENT EXISTING MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN NAPA
COUNTY AND COUNTY EMPLOYEES.
WITHOUT THIS CHANGE EIGHT
TORTURED PROCESS OF VOTES THE
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS THREATENS
EMPLOYEE PAY BENEFITS AND
RETIREMENT. IN CAUSES ENORMOUS
DELAYS IN IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COUNTIES COST SHARING AGREEMENT
WHICH IS UNIQUE BECAUSE IT'S
ADJUSTED ANNUALLY. WE ARE
WORKING WITH SEIU STATE COUNCIL
TO ASSURE THAT THE PROCESS IS
TRANSPARENT AND WILL REPORT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE IF ANY FURTHER
AMENDMENTS ARMY CORPS REQUIRED
TO MEET THE GOAL.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
SUPPORT ARMANI RATIGAN AND
HEATHER RUIZ FROM THE COUNTY OF
NAPA.
GORE.
HI HEATHER RUIZ AND THE HR
DIRECTOR FOR NAPA COUNTY.
CHO SHARING IS AN ISSUE WHEN
EMPLOYEES BEGIN TO PAY A PORTION
OF THE EMPLOYER IDENTIFIED
CALPERS CONTRIBUTION. NAPA
COUNTY BARGAIN IMPLEMENTED
AGREEMENTS WITH OUR UNIONS THAT
INCLUDES A METHODOLOGY TO SHARE
COST INCREASES A BETWEEN
EMPLOYEES IN THE COUNTY THIS
PRACTICE HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR
ABOUT A DECADE.
IT WASN'T UNTIL FISCAL YEAR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
THAT WAS THE FIRST YEAR WE
STARTED THOSE SHARED COST
INCREASES STARTED CAUSING
EMPLOYEES TO PAY A PORTION OF
THE EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION.
SO THAT'S WHAT CAUSED THIS
PROBLEM FOR US ACCORDING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROCESS.
I JUST DESCRIBED ON COST
SHARING REQUIRES THE CALPERS
CONTRACT AMENDMENT. THAT'S A
FOUR MONTH PROCESS.
THAT REQUIRES US TO TAKE THREE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ACTION AND
REQUIRES A VOTE OF OUR
EMPLOYEES.
THESE EMPLOYEES THAT ALREADY
VOTED TO ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT THE
MO YOU IN WHICH THIS LANGUAGE
EXISTS
SO IT FEELS LIKE A DUPLICATIVE
EFFORT TO ASK THEM TO DO THAT.
IT'S ALSO FOR US HAVE TO HAPPEN
ANNUALLY BECAUSE OUR COST
SHARING CHANGES ANNUALLY WITH
CALPERS RATES.
AND BECAUSE THE LENGTH OF THE
AMENDMENT PROCESS AND THE TIMING
OF OUR BARGAINING IT OFTEN
OCCURS THE WERE UNABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THE CALPERS AMENDMENT
BY THE BEGINNING OF THE FISCAL
YEAR. WHAT THAT CREATES?
BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN THE RATES
CHANGE WITH THAT CREATES IS
EMPLOYEES CONTRIBUTIONS AIR OUT
AND WHEN THE COUNTY TRIES TO
REPORT THOSE TO CALPERS.
AND SO THEREFORE EMPLOYEES AND
UP WITH CONTRIBUTIONS AND
SERVICE NOT BEING REPORTED ON
THEIR ACCOUNT TIMELY.
AND THE PROPOSED CHANGE BEFORE
YOU WOULD MODIFY THE CALPERS
LAW.
TO RECOGNIZE OUR APPROVED AND
WILL YOU LANGUAGE.
FOR RATE CHANGES ELIMINATING
THE REQUIREMENT FOR THAT
EMPLOYEE ELECTION WHICH HELP
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR US.
IT HONORS OUR BINDING AGREEMENTS
WITH OUR UNIONS.
BETWEEN COUNTY ANY UNION IT
STREAMLINES THIS ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS FOR THE COUNTY.
AND I WOULD JUST DIE NEXT MOLLY
RIGHT AGAIN AYE DEPUTY COUNTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
INTERGOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR
NAPA COUNTY HERE ON THE BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SUPPORT WOULD BE A STRONG WORD.
WERE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR THEIR
STAFF.
FOR ACCOMMODATING SEIU
CALIFORNIA'S CONCERNS ABOUT WE
BELIEVE THERE'S PROBABLY A SWEET
SPOT BETWEEN THE. NOT
SURPRISINGLY CALPERS CUMBERSOME
PROCESS AND NO NOTICE AND WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND THAT'S BOTTON
BELIEVE WILL BE A BLACK COMMISH
THAT ACCOMPLISH THAT AS WE. MOVE
FORWARD TECHIES.
WITH THAT KIND JUST GET YOU TO
STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD
UP THANKS JERRY BROWN AND ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SE NON ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE.
C. NONE OF BACKED UP TO THE
COMMITTING ANY QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SE NON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ALL YES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE INTO JUST ASSURE YOU THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK BOTH WITH
COUNTING SLU TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS. A WORKABLE AGREEMENT FOR
BOTH.
THANK YOU MUCH WHAT WE HAVE HARM
WON'T BRING UP FOR VOTE AND I TO
HELP IRAQ WAS ONE THINKING.
WITH THAT SAID WE HAVE A MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLACE AB THIRTY
ONE FORTY FIVE SIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
I PRESENT BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
FIVE WOULD ALLOW EXCLUDED STATE
EMPLOYEES TO ELECT.
GENERAL AND STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAMS IN LIEU OF
RECEIVING NON INDUSTRIAL
DISABILITY INSURANCE COVERAGE IN
ORDER TO ALLOW THESE WORKERS TO
BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE. PAID
FAMILY LEAVE
AB MEMBERS EITHER JUST.
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE APPOINTED
EITHER BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OR THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE THAT
ARE BEING EXCLUDED RIGHT NOW
FROM BEING ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS HAS.
BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THAT
INEQUITY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
SENATE HEARING NONE ANY COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THAT SAID WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU SALAS QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
UP WE HAVE A QUORUM AND I DO
HAVE OUR WORK ON THIS AS WELL SO
THANKS VERY MUCH PRESENT YOU
I'M.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ WILL NOT GO TO
AB TWENTY THREE OH FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE OH FIVE WILL
CODIFY. THE EXISTING PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES REACHED FIBRILLATION
BORDER PURPOSE CASE.
WHICH GIVES PER JURISDICTION
OVER PEACE OFFICER EMPLOYER
MUSICIAN.
DISPUTES.
AND NINETEEN NINETY NINE
LEGISLATION INTRODUCED TO GET
PER EXECUTIVE JURISDICTION OVER
VIOLATIONS OF ANY ROADS ARE
REGULATIONS BY LOCAL AGENCIES
HOWEVER.
EXCLUDED ANY ORGAN RICK
RECOGNIZE THEM PLOY
ORGANIZATIONS WHO REPRESENTS.
PEACE OFFICERS
AS RICH AS A RESULT PEACE
OFFICER MUST MAKE THEIR DISPUTES
TO SUPERIOR COURTS.
SUPER COURTS ARE NOT ONLY
BECAUSE SHE BUT THERE ARE ALSO
NOT WELL EQUIPPED.
TO COVER TO COVER LABOR CASES
LIKE PER.
AB TWENTY THREE A FIVE WILL GIVE
SMALL POLICE OFFICER
ORGANIZATIONS ABILITY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES. AGAINST UNFAIR
PRACTICES.
CONTRACT DISPUTES AND BAD FAITH
BARGAINING.
WITH ME TODAY IS QUITE PROFOUND
QUESTIONS OF KEVIN MICKELSON
PRESIDENT SEKHEMRE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES
ASSOCIATION AND STRAIN OF ON
LIVING ON BEHALF OF SPONSOR THEM
MUCH OF THAT MEDICAL. I DON'T
SEE MISTER LEVINE.
ARE.
I DON'T SEE THAT WE ARE OKAY.
IT.
MISTER CHAIR I'VE BEEN ALL
TOMORROW I'M HERE FOR MISTER
LEVINE.
ALSO I HE'S STUCK IN COMMITTEE.
NEXT DOOR SO WE WERE TOGETHER
YASMINA COMING HERE ON HIS
BEHALF BUT I'M.
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION
ORANGE COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
THE LONG BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
AS WELL AS THE FRATERNAL ORDER
OF POLICE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS. ASSOCIATION ALL
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND OUR
WITNESSES APPEARS WELL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MY NAME
IS KEVIN NICHOLSON I'M PRESIDENT
OF THE SOCK MCCAIN IF THE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND A
MEMBER OF THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE THE SECOND LARGEST LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TODAY ON
BEHALF OF MY ASSOCIATION AND
CLOSE TO THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS
WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY THREE OH FIVE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT MY ASSOCIATION
IN PARTICULAR FOR TOO LONG HAVE
SEEN THE LABOR DISPUTES RANGING
FROM UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICES
BREACHES OF CONTRACT OR BAD
FAITH BARGAINING SENT TO
SUPERIOR COURT. THIS IS HIGHLY
PROBLEMATIC FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS.
AB TWENTY THREE OH FIVE SIMPLY
CODIFIED A PURPOSE ASIAN FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHICH GIVES
PER OF JURISDICTION OVER PEACE
OFFICER EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS WILL CREATE CERTAINTY IN
THAT LAW.
THERE ARE FEW REASONS WE'RE
SEEKING THE STATUTORY CHANGE
FIRST PURSUING CLAIMS IN
SUPERIOR COURT CAN BE TOO
COSTLY.
A SUPERIOR COURT FILING FOR
LABOR DISPUTE CAN COST A PEACE
OFFICER THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IT
IS NOT RARE FOR THESE CASES TO
INCUR COSTS UPWARDS OF FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHILE A SIMILAR
FOUNDING EMPEROR. WOULD
GENERALLY BE WELL UNDER FIVE
THOUSAND.
MOST LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATIONS IN THE STATE ARE
RELATIVELY SMALL WITH LIMITED
FINANCIAL RESOURCES WHEN ONE OF
THESE PEACE OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS
ARE DECIDING WHETHER TO TAKE A
CONTRACT DISPUTE TO COURT THE
MERE COST OF THIS MUST BE
CONSIDERED. AND MANY TIMES THESE
CLAIMS ARE NOT TAKING THE COURT
SOLELY DUE TO COST.
THIS IS A THIS IS CREATING A
DETERRENT BY DOING SO THIS GIVES
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND MANAGEMENT
AND UNFAIR ADVANTAGE.
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
ASSOCIATIONS DO NOT HAVE THIS
BURDEN BECAUSE THEY ARE UNDER
THE JURISDICTION OF PERM. WHICH
IS ABOUT WHICH IN MOST CASES IS
NOT COST PROHIBITIVE.
SECONDLY PURPOSE THE KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERTISE OVER UNFAIR LABOR
CLAIMS BECAUSE THESE ARE ONLY
TYPES OF CASES THEY HERE IN
CONTRAST SUPERIOR COURTS
COVERING NEARLY OUT OF SUBJECT
MATTERS INCLUDING CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL LITIGATION.
THIS MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THE COURTS TO MAKE CONSISTENT
FINDINGS ON ISSUES SUCH AS BAD
FAITH BARGAINING.
THESE CASES ARE COMPLEX AND
UNIQUE TO THE LABOR MANAGEMENT
RELATIONSHIPS.
AB TWENTY THREE OH FIVE WILL
ALLOW PEACE OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS
TO DRAW FROM THE EXPERTISE OF
PER AND GIVE THE SMALLER PEACE
OFFICER UNIONS. THE ABILITY TO
BEND DEFEND THEMSELVES AGAINST
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICES CONTRACT
DISPUTES AND BAD FAITH
BARGAINING BY REMOVING THE
BARRIER OF EXCESSIVE COSTS.
INCURRED BY THE COURTS.
BASED ON THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
.
IS THERE ARE IS THERE ANY OTHER
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR JOSH
WHAT'LL CHO WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT.
APPOINTMENTS CHAIR RANGE FROM
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
VERY BROAD ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS WE HAVE. POLICE
OFFICERS BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
A SINGLE OTHER SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION
SEEING OPPOSITION NINETY
COMMENTS FROM ANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY WE WILL WAIT FOR MOTION
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
WITH THAT.
THANK YOU THEY DON'T.
A PLEASE CLOSE PLEASE CLOSE.
ATTORNEY LIKE I HAVE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES WHEN.
DID YOU WANT A CLOSED BOOK AB
SHORTLY AFTER I VOTE AND THE
THINGS YOU CLOSE.
ALRIGHT GREAT WILL MOVED FILE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT BY
MISTER RODRIGUEZ AGAIN AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY EIGHT IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN.
GOOD MORNING WHICH CHAIR MEMBER
TEMPERS NE AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
THE CCPOA REPRESENTS THE HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN WHO KEEP
OUR CORRECTIONAL FACILITY SAFE.
OFTENTIMES AGAINST VIOLENT
INMATES
THIS MEASURE IS INTENDED TO
MEMORIALIZE THE CCP ALWAYS
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
AFTER NEGOTIATIONS ARE
COMPLETED.
THESE AGREEMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR RETIRED
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS HAVE
ADEQUATE HEALTH BENEFITS. AFTER
THEIR SERVICE
HERE WITH ME TODAY THE SIOBHAN
BAKER FROM CCPOA. WHO CAN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS?
AND THE MORNING WAS CHAIR
MEMBERS JIM I'M BAKER HOW BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION THIS MORNING.
THIS IS COMMON PRACTICE FOR THE
ASSOCIATION TO RUN A STAND ALONE
BILL.
WERE FULLY AWARE THEY GOVERNOR
BROWN.
PREFERS TO RUN A MORE YOU BILLS
AS AS BUDGET TRAILER BILLS.
I BUT WE JUST TAKE THIS
ASSURANCE ON BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND.
PEACE OFFICERS NEARLY TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND PEACE OFFICERS
THAT WE REPRESENT.
SO AS OF RIGHT NOW.
IT IS A SPOT BILL.
WITH VERY EARLY.
AND IN THE NEGOTIATING PROCESS
JUST ABOUT A MONTH OR SO. WE ARE
NOW DAHLE PRIVY TOANY OF THE
DETAILS AT THIS POINT.
HOWEVER WANT TO DEAL IS DONE
NGUYEN AND WE INTEND TO SHARE
ALL THE DETAILS WITH EACH
MEMBER.
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
.
SO COME BEFORE YOU TODAY AB
REQUESTING YOUR CONSIDERATION TO
ALLOW THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD
AND NOW RESPECTFULLY ASK WE AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
A
EIGHT KNOW OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
MISSING OPPOSITION NAY BECAUSE
REALLY COMMITTEE MEMBER SEE NO
COMMENTS.
WE WAIT FOR A MOTION TO SUCH
TIMES WE HAVE A QUORUM DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE. RESPECT AS FOR
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU. WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO.
.
I FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN.
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE A IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST WORKPLACE SEXUAL.
HARASSMENT.
CURRENTLY THE STATE BLOCKS A
CENTRALIZED SYSTEM FOR REPORTING
AND TRUCKING OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS BY THAT
STATE AGENCIES.
THIS BILL WERE CREDIT SYSTEM AND
REQUIRE THE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY OFFICER IN EACH
STATE AGENCY. AND DEPARTMENT TO
REPORT THE NUMBER OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS FILED. AND
STUFF OUT AND RECEIVED BY THE
STATE EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY PAID TO SETTLE A
COMPLAINT.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES CALORIE
CHART IN THE PART OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING TO
COLLECT INFORMATION.
FROM STATE AGENCIES AND REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND PUBLIC.
MEMBERS TRANSPARENCY CREATED BY
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENABLE THE
STATE. TO IDENTIFY PATTERNS OF
MISCONDUCT IN THE ELIMINATE
ABUSE AND INAPPROPRIATE
BEHAVIOR.
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO SUPPORT
IT.
SPONSORED BY SO YOU ONE THOUSAND
ASKED ME.
WITH WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS DOREEN STATEMENT A
REGISTERED NURSE AT RJ DONOVAN.
STATE PRISON AND MEMBER OF SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
THANK YOU GUIDE YOUR WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DORRIE STEDMAN AND I'M A MEMBER
LEADER AT SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND. MY UNION SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND REPRESENTS OVER
NINETY SIX THOUSAND STATE
EMPLOYEES I'M A REGISTERED NURSE
AT RJ DONOVAN STATE PRISON AND I
AM HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTEEN.
NO EMPLOYEE SHOULD HAVE TO FACE
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORKPLACE
INCLUDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT YET
THE SAD REALITY IS THAT MANY
WOMEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
SUBJECTED TO THIS INAPPROPRIATE
AND PERVERSE BEHAVIOR AT WORK.
WE MUST ELIMINATE ALL FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION AND ESPECIALLY
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BECAUSE PEOPLE
SHOULD FEEL SAFE IN THEIR
WORKPLACE.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WHICH IF LEFT
UNCHECKED CAN LEAD TO AN ABUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE PERPETRATOR IS
PROTECTIVE. BUT THE EMPLOYEE IS
NOT.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE AT RJ DONOVAN
PRISON IN SAN DIEGO BUT I'M ALSO
A UNION STEWARD FOR SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND OVER THE YEARS I'VE
HAD MANY MEMBERS COME TO ME FOR
HELP BECAUSE THEY WERE BEING
SEXUALLY HARASSED AT WORK.
SOMETIMES I FEEL POWERLESS
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T APPEAR THAT
ANYONE IS BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE MANDATORY REPORTING SYSTEM
REQUIRED IN AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN WILL ASSIST THE STATE
THE LEGISLATOR. AND THE PUBLIC
WITH IDENTIFYING PATTERNS OF
MISCONDUCT ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCIES THROUGH CENTRALIZED
SYSTEM FOR TRACKING COMPLAINTS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT. PREVENTING
INDIVIDUALS FROM AVOIDING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE ABILITY
TO MOVE THROUGH THE STATE SYSTEM
UNDETECTED.
BY TRACKING THESE COMPLAINTS IN
A CENTRALIZED MANNER THE STATE
CAN IDENTIFY PATTERSON VIEWS.
PINPOINT WORKPLACE CULTURES THAT
FOSTER INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR
AND ASSESS GAPS IN TRAINING.
WITH THIS INFORMATION WE BELIEVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN BE
THE LEADER IN CREATING A MODEL
OF A SAFE WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENT.
ON BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND NINETY SIX THOUSAND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
FOR AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IT'S TIME WE GIVE A
VOICE TO THE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COOLEY PLEASE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
WE DON'T HAVE A.
WITHOUT OF.
RODRIGUEZ.
HER.
ALLEN.
BRILL.
CERVANTES.
COOLEY.
COOPER YOUR.
O'DONNELL HERE.
ARE YOUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
I'M ONLY A GRIFFIN GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE RECORD EARLIER GRIFFING
WITH AT THE AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES DISTRICT COUNCIL FIFTY
SEVEN. AND HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR
STATE EMPLOYEES AT LOCAL TWENTY
SIX TWENTY AND STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE REASONS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN
BAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE HAVE SEEN OUR UNIONS
I'M ALL GRAPPLE WITH THE
CHALLENGE OF TAKING ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. AND HOW WE CAN BEST
PROTECT OUR MEMBERS AND WE
COMMEND THE WORK THAT LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND IS DOING WITH MISTER
RODRIGUEZ TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED
THINKING GREAT THANK YOU WHERE
IT'S TO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES.
AND ANY KIND OF MICRO JUSTINIANO
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE.
JUST WILL QUIT THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MISINFORMED PLOYS ON BEHALF OF
OUR STATE EMPLOYEES AT THE UNION
OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS IN SUPPORT.
MISS CHAIR MEMBERS KOBE PRESIDE
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
BILL.
A SCENE OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY.
PROVIDING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE MOTION IS ONE MOMENT.
I DO PASS.
TO.
DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY.
I WITH THAT PLEASE CLOSE.
A SHORT REST RIVAL THANK YOU
HAVE A A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOST IN IN THE MOTION AGAIN
IS TO PASS TO DO TO JUDICIARY.
WE DO A MOTION A SECOND TYPE OF
MOVE BY MR COOLEY SECOND BY
MISTER COOPER.
RODRIGUEZ
I RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
BREAUX CERVANTES COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE COOPER AYE AYE COOPER AYE
O'DONNELL AYE AYE O'DONNELL AYE.
AND.
I MISSED RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE LEAVING
SORGE CONTINUE ON I BELIEVE
MISTER SANTIAGO IS OUT THERE.
OKAY MAY PROCEED WHEN READY ARE
MISTER SANTIAGO HAS.
FILE AND OR FOURTEEN AB TWO
EIGHT SIX EIGHT TWO EIGHT SIX
ST.
MISTER CHAIR WOULD BE OKAY IF.
THE FIGHT WILL GO IF WE START
OFF WITH A NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN.
I GOT TO EIGHT SIX EIGHT FILE
UNDER FOURTEEN FROM ME.
WE GIVE THEM WHAT WHAT ARE DOING
HERE.
I AM VERY YOU WANNA START WITH A
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN YES PLEASE
YES KIDS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
I APOLOGIZE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE WILL START WITH THAT GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I THINK MR CHAIR A. B. NINETEEN
THIRTY SEVEN WITH STANDARDIZING
CLARIFY EXISTING LAWS IMPACT IN
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYERS. AND
EMPLOYERS ACES WITH REGARD TO
EXISTING PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS
OTHER OPOSSUM THEIR TO ABOUT A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING I'M
STATURE IS COVERING PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN THEIR EMPLOYERS AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES.
I'LL ALL THESE ARE LAWS ADOPTED
DURING DIFFERENT TIMES WHILE
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDING THE SAME
RIGHTS
I WOULD WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
STANDARDIZE OF THE PROCESS.
AND RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
EMPLOYEE.
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE EMPLOYERS
AS REAL IN THAT RELATES TO
ADDUCE DEDUCTIONS OF MOVIE I.
I MOVED INTO SECOND MOVE BY MR
COOPER SECOND BY MISTER COOLEY.
YOUR OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
MICHELLE CAST OF THE
SOME PLACE IN ANNOUNCED WHEN
UNION.
OFFICIALLY THIS BILL AS A
COMPANION MEASURE TO AB TWENTY
FORTY NINE WHICH PASSES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL FOURTH.
THERE VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL
EXCEPT FOR THAT BILL ONLY APPLY
TO CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
AND.
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS THIS BOOK
COVERS ALL OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES
AND AS MR SANTIAGO SAID THIS IS
A. REALLY SIMPLE BILL TO
STANDARDIZE AND CLARIFY.
CURRENT LAW CASE LAW PRACTICES
ARM TOWARD ANY AMBIGUITIES IN
QUESTIONS WITH REGARD TO DUTIES
AND FUNCTIONS BOTH UNIONS AND
EMPLOYERS HAVE. IT IS CONSISTENT
AGAIN WITH CASE ALL CURRENT
STATUTE AND PRACTICE ON IT JUST
REALLY GETS RID OF QUESTIONS
THAT OUR CURRENT LAW WE ASK FREE
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JOSHUA LOCAL WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MISS CASTRO WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN BEG FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
SUPPORT.
AS CHAIR RYAN CHEN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
TO CHECK MEMBERS PACMAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS CHRISTIE
BELL ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
TEACHERS WERE HIS HOUSE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN NUMBERS SHE BONDED
MANGAS WITH UT W. OFFICE ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN
SUPPORT.
CENTER RURAL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
SHARE MEMBERS GO BEAT HIS IDEA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS AND
SUPPORT.
VERY BROAD TEAMSTERS AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION MACHINISTS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION.
I'VE DATE HUTCHINGS WITH THAT OF
THE CALIFORNIA IS WE DO NOT HAVE
A POSITION ABOUT HOW A FRAME BOB
COVERING FOR DIRTY JOBS ANOTHER
NEW TRACK. DODD THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT OKAY OTHERS IN THE ROOM.
ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I HAD NOT SEEN NO OF FOR THE
CULTURE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE
DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
ALREADY I BELIEVE.
PLEASE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTES
OR.
UP.
THE MOTION IS I DO PASS
AND RE REFER.
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
OKAY EVERY AND.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RODRIGUEZ.
ALLEN.
BROUGH CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER I
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE.
SO WE'RE GOOD NOW GO TO.
.
YEAH BUT I AND NUMBER FOURTEEN
AB TWENTY. EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT BY
MISTER SANTIAGO AGAIN PLEASE.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT A SECOND BILL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT I
WOULD PROVIDE THAT LAW CLERKS IN
LA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
EMPLOYEES.
IT THAT IF HERE SHE IS IS IS
EMPLOYED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS THAT WOULD BECOME A
PERMANENT EMPLOYEE.
THANK YOU BEEN MOVED A SECOND GO
AHEAD.
HAVING HEARD A FIRST AND SECOND
I WILL BE BRIEF AND A SIMPLY
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I
HAVE TO REPRESENTATIVES HERE.
WHO'LL SPEAK BRIEFLY WELL.
MY NAME IS KAREN TESTER GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS.
I'M HERE SPEAKING WITH COUNSEL
THIRTY SIX.
A.
AT THAT THE EMPLOYEES UNION TO
ASK ME AND INDIVIDUALLY JUST FOR
BACK GROUND INFORMATION I'M ALSO
RESEARCH ATTORNEY AT LA SUPERIOR
COURT. UNION REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT.
ON A BIG SCALE IT WOULD BE
VIEWED AS A POLICY TO.
.
ALLOCATE NEW FUNDING THAT'S
COMING TO THE COURTS.
IN THE WORKS.
TO THE BEST USES.
.
AND.
LOS ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT DOES
JUST ONE INSTANCE ARM.
JUST.
ONE RESEARCH ATTORNEY OR LAW
CLERK WORKS FOR TWO JUDGES
TYPICALLY WITH US SOME
EXCEPTIONS.
SO EXPERTISE KNOWLEDGE
HARDWORKING EFFICIENCY ARE
ESSENTIAL.
.
SOME STATES SOME IN STATE COURTS
SEVERAL EXPRESSED A PREFERENCE
TO HER LIMITED TERM LAW CLERKS.
UP YOU SURVEY THE COURTS ON
STATEWIDE THAT'S BECOME.
OUTDATED AND MIGHT MINORITY
VIEW FOR DECADES.
OF MOST OF THE COURTS THAT ALONG
OF HAD CAREER RESEARCH TURNED
HIS.
.
FEDERAL COURTS ALSO HAVE MIXED
THOUGH.
CAREER AND.
LIMIT TERM LAW CLERKS.
IF.
LA SUPERIOR COURT COULD
ALLOCATE FUNDING LIKE FEDERAL
TRIAL COURTS WHERE YOU GET TWO
OR THREE LAW CLERKS PER JUDGE.
THEN PERHAPS TRAINING ON.
LIMITED TERM CLERKS.
FREQUENTLY ON AN ONGOING BASIS
WOULD WORK.
BETTER.
.
AND OF COURSE.
TRAINING NEW LOCKER TO THAT
LAUDABLE GOAL THAT ALSO CAN BE
DONE BY VOLUNTEER EXTERNSHIPS.
.
THE UNION HAS TRIED ARE
RESOLVING THIS WITH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THAT HASN'T WORKED
FOR MANY YEARS.
THEY TRIED ARBITRATION IT DIDN'T
CHANGE THINGS.
THE BILL A SIMILAR SIMILAR
BILLS ALREADY PASSED TWICE.
.
THE PRIOR GOVERNOR BUTTE VETO
THOSE.
THEN FINALLY.
.
THE UNION REPRESENT REFERENCES
GOVERNMENT CALLED SEVEN ONE SIX
OH ONE MAJORITY LIMITS TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEE TERMS TO HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS. AND THE EVEN ASK YOU.
HAVING LIMITED TERM LAW CLERKS
FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
MAXIMUM FITS WITH A POLICY OF
THAT STATUTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT MORNING ADAM ACOSTA ACTS
FOR SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT FROM AFRIKAANS
THIRTY SIX.
AND ONCE SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE UP
BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES OR I.
WANT TO I JUST ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WHERE CO SPONSORING AND
SUPPORTING OUR AFFILIATE ASKED
ME DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX
IS THE FACT THAT IT EFFICIENTLY.
AS AND WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR. IT
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VAGUE FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION PARENTS SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
MONNING MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
LARA SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
LEAVING THAT INAPPROPRIATELY
INTERFERES WITH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS THINK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
SE NON ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SOME WOMEN LIKE CLOSE.
YES AND THANK YOU FOR.
HAPPENS HERE TODAY AS ONE
SIMPLY REITERATE ONE MORE TIME.
IT.
THAT THAT THE LAW WAS
ORIGINALLY MEANT FOR TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEE.
TO BE THERE FOR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS AFTER THAT THEY
WOULD BECOME A PERMANENT
EMPLOYEE. AYE AND THIS BILL SEE
IT WANTS TO. PREVENT THEM FROM A
SKIRT IN THE LAW WHICH IS
THEY'LL USE.
THEY'LL USE A A LIMITED TIME A
LOT CLERK INSTEAD OF.
A TEMPORARY EMPLOYEE WHICH IS
THE SAME THING.
AND CONTINUED TO RECYCLE PEOPLE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS WITHOUT
MAKING HIM A PROMINENT PLOY
THAT'S WHAT REALLY THIS IS ALL
ABOUT SO WE WANT TO STOP THAT.
THE BAD BEHAVIOR AND POTENTIAL
AND ALSO THE ABUSE ON EMPLOYEES
A CONTINUE TO GO TO THE SYSTEM
WITHOUT BECOMING. A PERMANENT
FULL TIME EMPLOYEES AND WE ASK
THAT THIS COMMITTEE FOR AN AYE
VOTE BECAUSE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT I DO HAVE I
RECKON THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. AND WITHOUT
TO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
O'DONNELL SECOND I'M SCHOOLING.
A SECRETARY LIKE KALRA.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND WE REFERRED AT THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN. BROUGH
CERVANTES COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER. COOPER AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
OKAY THAT MEASURES ON CALL.
THANK YOU MUCH.
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
HERE TO PRESENT ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT.
THIRTY.
S. RAISE MINORITY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY ASKS THAT
COUNTIES GIVE PRIORITY TO
CURRENT CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH HOME.
HOMELESS YOUTH INFORMALLY
INCARCERATED YOUTH WHEN OFFERING
INTERNSHIPS OR TRANSITIONING
INTERNS FROM PERMANENT.
OUR INTO PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT.
THE TRANSITION FROM ADOLESCENCE
TO ADULTHOOD CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT.
AND INTIMIDATING.
AND TO THIS.
AND THIS BILL THEN WILL HELP US
TO TRANSITION THEM WITH US
TODAY.
I.
APPRECIATE HOPE YOU'LL
APPRECIATE THE BREVITY WITH US
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THE
BILL IS MICHAEL STOOD EURO FROM
JOURNEY HOUSE.
I THANK YOU AND I WILL SPARE YOU
MY LIST OF.
STATISTICS.
I WANNA SHARE ONE ASPECT.
THAT MIGHT HIT CLOSE TO HOME
FOR YOU.
SHADOW DAY FOR FOSTER THIS
COMING UP IN MAY.
THE INCEPTION OF THAT CAME FROM
AN EMPLOYEE HERE CWD A AS A
SURROGATE FOR TAKE YOUR KIDS TO
WORK DAY.
BECAUSE AS A FORMER FOSTER WITH
MYSELF.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
OR. THOSE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WERE AVAILABLE TO US WERE SO
GREAT FOR AND OPPORTUNITY LIKE
THAT.
AS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WE
DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
LIVE AT HOME AFTER COLLEGE IF WE
GET TO GO TO COLLEGE
OR USE THE FAMILY CAR. OR GET A
LOAN OR USE THE CONNECTIONS THAT
ARE FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE TO GET
JOBS.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU I WENT
FROM BEING HOMELESS TO EARNING A
PHD.
MY NAME'S DOCTORS TO DURA.
I WENT FROM LIVING IN A HOMELESS
SHELTER TO GETTING MY BACHELOR'S
DEGREE A FIVE YEAR PERIOD OF
TIME.
UPON WHICH I WAS THE US ARMY
OFFICER.
MY EXPERIENCE WAS DIFFERENT
ALLIE HAD FOR FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENTS BROWN BEHALF OF MY
YOUNGER BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES.
THANK YOU ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ANY
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATE HEARING NONE MEMBER JOE
LIKE CLOSE.
YES I JUST WANT TO ECHO. DOCTORS
TO JUROR'S COMMENTS.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DO HAVE AN
AYE RECORD.
WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
ONCE WE GET.
EVERYONE I THINK WE CAN ALL I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND.
SO SECRETARY LIKE CALDERON.
IF THE MOTION IS DUE PASSING BE
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN BROUGH
CERVANTES.
COOLEY.
COOPER O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE MOTION DON'T CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
.
SO WITHOUT THAT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ HERE TO PRESENT
HAN.
AB TWENTY FORTY EIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
HELP YOUR INFORMED WE GOT.
SOME ELSE PRESENT YOUR BILL AND.
A GREAT HONOR TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THIS BILL IN FRONT OF.
ONLY THE CHAIR.
THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL.
AB TWENTY FORTY EIGHT.
SIMPLY HOLDS US TO THE SAME
STANDARD.
THAT WE EXPECT UP EVERY SINGLE
EMPLOYER IN CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF US FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN IS A
FUNDAMENTAL WORKPLACE RIGHT.
IT IS A RIGHT THAT WE HAVE
GRANTED.
FEDERALLY TO ALL PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYERS.%
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
CLOSE THOSE LOOPHOLES FOR PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES.
FARMWORKERS AND NOW WHAT I'M
ASKING TO CLOSE THE FINAL
LOOPHOLE FOR OUR OWN MEMBERS.
THIS INSTITUTION WAS ROCKED LAST
YEAR.
BY SCANDAL.
AFTER SCANDAL.
OF ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND RETALIATION.
WE PACKED PAST ABUSES ABOUT
WORKPLACE BULLYING AND WE'VE
FOUND LIKE ANY WORKPLACE.
WHERE THERE IS?
AN IMBALANCE OF POWER.
THAT WORKERS HAVE NO RECOURSE.
THAT THEY HAVE NO ABILITY TO
COME FORWARD IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT.
TO WORK TOGETHER TO CHANGE THEIR
WORKPLACE.
OFTEN PEOPLE THINK ABOUT THE
RIGHT TO UNIONIZE IN TERMS
A PAY AND BENEFITS.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE THIS.
BUILDING WOULD AGREE THAT THEIR
BENEFITS.
ARE QUITE GOOD.
HAVING COVER LABOR MOVEMENT I
DON'T THINK I'VE SEEN MUCH
BETTER.
THE PROBLEMS WITH PAYING WE'VE
KNOWN THAT WE'VE TAKEN SOME
STEPS TO ADDRESS PAY INEQUITIES
BUT THERE'S STILL PROBLEMS.
AND IT'S THERE'S NO UNIFORMITY
THERE'S NO RIGHTS FOR ANY
INDIVIDUAL WORKER. THERE SOME
RULES THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
APPLIED.
AND AS A RESULT IT'S.
SLIGHTLY UNFAIR.
BUT WHAT'S MOST STRIKING.
IF THERE'S A WORKPLACE CULTURE
THAT DOESN'T ALLOW THE VERY
WORKERS WHO ALLOW US TO DO OUR
JOB.
WHO REALLY ARE THE BACKBONE OF
EVERYTHING WE DO? FOR THEM TO
HAVE A VOICE IN THEIR OWN
WORKPLACE.
FOR THEM TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS THAT THEY
SEE THAT EXIST.
I APPLAUD THE EFFORTS OF THE
SPEAKER IN THE PRO TEM AND THE
EFFORTS OF MEMBERS OF THIS BODY
TO COME TOGETHER AND HAVE A
JOINT COMMITTEE. TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES WE'VE SEEN.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST
AND ANY OTHER WORKPLACE
THAT WILL BE THE BOSS IS COMING
TOGETHER WITH OUTSIDE EXPERTS.
TO TELL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY FACING THESE ISSUES
WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT WHAT WILL
CORRECT
CULTURE FOR THEM.
THERE IS NO SUBSTANTIVE INPUT BY
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE VOICED THEIR
CONCERNS.
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS
BUILDING.
ONE WAY TO SOLVE THAT IN FACT
THE ONLY WAY I'VE EVER SEEN IN
ANY WORKPLACE TO SOLVE THAT.
IS TO ALLOW WORKERS THE CHANCE.
TO COME TOGETHER AND HAVE A
COLLECTIVE VOICE.
THIS BILL DOESN'T SAY THAT ANY
MEMBER OF ANYBODY STAFF WILL BE
IN A UNION.
THAT IS A RIGHT THAT SHOULD AND
WOULD ST WITH THE ACTUAL
WORKERS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE DEMAND
OF EVERY OTHER EMPLOYER.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES SIMPLY IS
NOT ONLY FOR OUR STAFF?
TELL THEM THAT WE RESPECT THEM
ENOUGH TO MAKE THAT CHOICE ON
THEIR OWN WITH OUT INTIMIDATION
AND WITHOUT RETALIATION.
BUT ALSO FOR THAT OTHER STAFF
THAT ARE NOT OUR DIRECT STAFF
WHO MAY ALSO HELP WORKPLACE
GRIPES.
WHETHER IT'S THE SERGEANTS TO
DRIVE US AROUND WHETHER IT'S THE
FOLKS WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
CLERK'S OFFICE TO PROCESS OUR
BILLS WHETHER IT'S ALLEGE
COUNSEL WHO WRITE OUR BILLS.
IT IS JUST A SIMPLE STATEMENT OF
ALLOWING WORKERS.
DOT RIGHT TO HAVE A VOICE IN TO
SAY WE RESPECT THEM ENOUGH TO
USE THAT VOICE RESPONSIBLY.
IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
THAT'S ALL THIS BILL DOES
I KNOW IT SCARES PEOPLE.
I'VE HAD VERY LITTLE HONEST
INTERACTION WITH ANYBODY ABOUT
THE OPPOSITION ALTHOUGH I KNOW
IT EXIST. ONLY.
AMONG THEIR OWN RANKS.
IF A MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD IN SUGGESTS TO ME LIKE
ANY OTHER PROCESS SUGGESTED AS.
AT LEAST ONE MEMBER HAS THAT
WERE UNIQUE.
WHERE SPECIAL?
WHAT DIFFERENT
WE DON'T NEED?
A UNION IN THIS WORKPLACE.
I CHALLENGE YOU TO SAY THAT
PUBLIC BECAUSE EVERY BOSS THINKS
THEY DON'T NEED A UNION IN THE
WORKPLACE.
AND IT IS THOSE BOSSES WHO VOICE
AT THE LOUDEST THAT USUALLY MEET
AT THE MOST.
SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR TODAY. I
AM ASKING.
FOR THE COURTESY OF MOVING A
BILL FORWARD.
THAT WOULD JUST CLEAR UP
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIPS IN THIS
BUILDING.
AND THAT WOULD SHOW OUR STAFF.
THAT WE RESPECT THEM ENOUGH TO
MAKE GOOD CHOICES FOR
THEMSELVES.
I HAVE A NUMBER OF WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU JUST MEMBERS JUST I
HAVE TWO MINUTE LIMIT ON
EVERYONE DUE TO THE NATURE OF
OUR AGENDA TODAY. SO WITH THAT
WHO'D LIKE TO GO FIRST.
AGO.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
BRIAN.
HOT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
APPEAR TODAY WEARING TWO HATS
I'M AS A FORMER SENATE EMPLOYEE.
I'M AND AS A UNIT EMPLOYEE AND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS.
I STARTED MY CAREER AS A SENATE
FOLLOW BACK IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
AND I WORK FOR THEIR. GREATEST
MEMBER BY NAY WITH JACK'S GOT NO
OFFENSE TO YOU KNOW THAT SOME OF
THE MEMBERS ON THAT SAID.
I STAYED WITH THEM UNTIL HIS
VERY LAST DAY TAKE TIME ABOUT
HOW TO HAVE A REASON TO LEAVE OR
SEEK ANOTHER JOB HE WAS.
JUST SIMPLY THE GREATEST MENTOR
BOSS ANYONE COULD ACTUALLY WHICH
FOR ABA FORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT
THE CASE TODAY.
.
IT I AM I'M ALSO ONE OF THE
FOUNDING MEMBERS FOR A PIZZA
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER CAPITAL
ASSOCIATION.
AND THIS BILL IS THE VERY THIS
BILL.
TRIES TO ACCOMPLISH THE VERY
THING THAT WE
I WERE SET OUT TO DO WHEN WE
WERE CREATING A PIZZA WE WERE
CHINA JUST PROVIDE SOME KIND OF
A SUPPORT NETWORK FOR STAFF.
ON THE BILL AGAIN YOU KNOW IF IF
IF MEMBERS CHOOSE TO. JOIN A
UNION WHERE WHERE SIMPLY GIVING
GRANTING THAT WENT WITH THAT
ACCESS FOR THEM TO UNIONIZE ON
ITS IT GO IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
THAN REPRESENTATION IS ACTUALLY
MORE THAN PROTECTION.
I KNOW THERE'S THAT MIGHT OUT
THERE ABOUT JOIN UNIONS BUT.
I CAN GO ON AND ON ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF THREATEN THE UNION.
BUT I WON'T AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ON.
PLENTY OF OTHER COLLEAGUES HERE
BUT DOWN AGAIN THIS IS A THIS IS
A VERY GOOD BILL.
IT OUT GIVEN GIVEN AND GIVEN
TODAY'S NATURE AND I STRONGLY
URGE ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
NEXT.
SHARE MEMBERS KOBE BESIDE HIM WE
HAVE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
.
YOU KNOW.
CAPTAIN BELIEVES THAT ALL OF OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN STATE
SERVICE SHOULD HAVE CERTAIN
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE DEFINED IN
THIS BILL.
SO WITH THAT I'LL SAY THAT IS
MY CAT. NOW MINUTES SPEAK ON
BEHALF AS A FORMER STAFFER.
I WORKED IN THE CAPITAL. FROM
NINETY SIX TO TWO THOUSAND ONE
FOR INDIVIDUAL ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
AND I WAS NOT AS FORTUNATE AS
BRIAN.
TO HAVE YOU KNOW. PEOPLE THAT
TREATED YOU ALWAYS WITH THE
RESPECT.
THAT YOU DESERVED.
I WAS ASKED ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS TO SHORE FLORA. A
MEMBERS.
SPOUSE AROUND IN MY OWN CAR ON
STATE TIME.
GO TO MEMBERS HOUSE TAKE APART
AND REASSEMBLE BED FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY PURCHASE SOMETHING.
BABY SIT THEIR CHILD.
ON STATE TIME.
YEAH THESE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT NO STAFF SHOULD
EVER.
BE ASKED TO DO.
I WAS TO AFRAID TO SPEAK OUT
THEN BUT WHEN I FINALLY DID
BRING SOMETHING UP TO MY CHIEF
OF STAFF.
I WAS CONSEQUENTLY LET GO ABOUT
A MONTH LATER GROUPS THE MEMBER
EXCITED.
THAT THEY WERE REORGANIZING.
TURNED OUT TO BE A BLESSING
BECAUSE I THEN WENT TO WORK FOR
TWO SPEAKERS.
SO IT FOR ME IT WORKED OUT IN
THE END. BUT NOBODY SHOULD EVER
HAVE TO DO THAT.
AND NOBODY SHOULD BE PUT IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY FEAR FOR
THEIR TOP.
SO WITH THAT.
THANK YOU NEXT.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS CLAYTON
MEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME
JUST ONE MINUTE I THINK HE ONLY
TOOK ONE. I KNOW TWO WITNESSES
BUT I THINK YOU ONLY TOOK ONE OF
THE VERY QUICK. I WOULD SIMPLY
SAY IF YOU LOOK THROUGH LABOR
HISTORY ALMOST EVERY GROUP OF
WORKERS WHEN THEY FOUGHT FOR THE
RIGHT TO ORGANIZE THEIR WORK. ON
STRONG OBJECTIONS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP OF WORKERS
COULDN'T UNIONIZE BECAUSE OF THE
GREATER GOOD THAT POLICE OFFICER
SHOULDN'T BE IN A UNION THAT
FIREFIGHTER SHOULDN'T BE IN THE
UNION THAT SOMEHOW THERE'S AN
INHERENT CONFLICT. BETWEEN THOSE
BASIC WORKPLACE RIGHTS AND BEING
PART OF A AND HAVING A MISSION
AND SERVING THE PUBLIC AND I
THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY NO CONFLICT OUR
POLICE ARE FIRE. OUR AND FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES ARE STATE EMPLOYEES
AND WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND COUNTRY. A ARE ABLE TO SERVE
THEIR MISSION ACT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THEIR BOSS DO THEIR
JOB BE PROFESSIONAL ON AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC WHILE ALSO
HAVING SOME MINIMAL PROTECTIONS.
SOME DUE PROCESS RIGHTS ON AND
SO WE SEE NO CONFLICT THAT
SHOULD EXIST HERE A WE HAVE
HEARD THESE ARGUMENTS EACH AND
SEEN
TOGETHER THEY'RE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT THAT
REFLECTS THE NEEDS AND DEMANDS
AND PRIORITIES OF THE PLACE THEY
WORK
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THINK
ANYONE SUPPORT IT OR ON BEHALF
OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION I WOULD ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF ALL OF THE
WITNESSES THAT WERE HERE TODAY
AND I'LL TRY TO KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF. I TOO AM A FORMAL CAPITOL
STAFFER AND HAVE EXPERIENCED
THIS AND THIS INSTITUTION IN A
WAY THAT'S BEEN VERY BENEFICIAL
TO ME HOWEVER I WILL SAY THAT
THE BALANCE OF POWER THAT WE
REQUEST FROM EMPLOYERS ACROSS
THE STATE. IS NECESSARY HERE AS
WELL AND I THINK WE DID HEAR
THAT THROUGH THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
THROUGH SOME OF THE STORIES
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY THAT THERE IS
AND AND THERE IS AN INHERENT
IMBALANCE OF POWER WHERE WORKERS
DON'T FEEL. THAT THEY HAVE A
VOICE TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS WHAT
THEY BELIEVE THEY CAN ENHANCE
THE INSTITUTION WITHIN ITSELF
THIS BILLS SIMPLY ASK THAT WE
GIVE THEM THE RIGHT TO DO THAT.
WE'VE ASKED MANY OF YOU ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO REACH OUT TO
SEVERAL EMPLOYERS ON OUR BEHALF
TO ORGANIZE WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE FOR THE VERY SAME REASONS
AND PUSH BACK THAT WE'RE GETTING
HERE WE ASK THAT WE ACTUALLY CAN
BE CONSISTENT IN OUR VALUES AND
OUR MORALS. AND ALLOW THE SAME
THING TO HAPPEN WITH CAPITAL
STAFF.
THANK YOU KNOW ONE OF SPORT.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES ON MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
BEEN ARE OFTEN IN TERMS OF.
THE INFORMATION THEY PROVIDED
ABOUT WHY THIS BILL IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO I WON'T
BELABOR THE POINT I WAS JUST
SIMPLY SAY THAT THIS IS A TIME
WHEN IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WORKERS.
THROUGHOUT.
EMPLOYMENT SECTORS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COME TOGETHER. AND AS
MISS VEGA.
MOST ELOQUENTLY POINTED OUT.
PULL TOGETHER AND NEGOTIATE
CONTRACTS THAT REPRESENT THE
VALUES ARE AND THE PRIORITIES
NOT ONLY OF THEMSELVES AS
EMPLOYEES BUT OUT OF IT AS THE
WORKPLACE AS.
THE PEOPLE'S INSTITUTION AND
HERE IN THE STATE CAPITAL WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL DOES
GIVES THOSE WORKERS THAT
OPPORTUNITY WOULD LIKE TO THANK.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD AND WHAT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
OF THE COMMITTEE.
THINK ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTY ABOUT
MOM BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THIRTY
THOUSAND PROUD STRONG UNION
MEMBERS.
GOING TO SHARE MY NAME IS TERRY
SCHANTZ I SERVED AS CHIEF OF
STAFF TO SOMEONE MEMBER KEVIN
MCCARTY. A BEEN ALLEGED TO HAVE
EMPLOYEE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS I
SUPPORT THIS BILL BY AS A MEMBER
WHO REPRESENTS.
AND MS MCCARTY REPRESENTS
MAJORITY OF A CAPITAL EMPLOYEES
THE LIVING WORKING SACRAMENTO A
WE PREVIEWED INCINERATION THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SIZE MANY OF YOU HAVE.
SAID TODAY FORMER STAFFERS I
MYSELF.
HAVE BEEN A FORMER STAFFER FOR
THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND WHAT I RECOGNIZE DESIRE.
MANY LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEES
ARE DRAWN TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
I HAVE THE DESIRE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR STATE IN THE
WORLD.
ONCE HIRED EMPLOYEES SHOULD NOT
FEEL POWERLESS ON THEIR JOB.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
ISSUES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THIS INSTITUTION HAS NOT BEEN
MODERNIZE SINCE THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TODAY.
TO CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION.
AND HOW WE NEED TO UPHOLD OUR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY IN OUR
DUTY TO THE STATE.
SO I WITHOUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING.
THE BILL.
TODAY THANK YOU.
NOT THAT I MEMBERS LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I REALIZE THAT FOR VOTE TO TAKE
PLACE THAT I NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
I WOULD I. RESPECTFULLY.
ASK.
THAT ONCE THE MOTION IS MADE
THAT THE CHAIR MIGHT CONSIDER
SECOND THAT MOTION.
SO THAT WECAN HAVE A DISCUSSION
AN HONEST DISCUSSION.
ABOUT WHO WE ARE AS A PARTY.
IT'S EASY.
TO DISMISS A CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUE.
BY SIMPLY NOT ALLOWING IT TO BE
VOTED ON.
IT WAS HARD TO GET THIS BILL
HERE.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S PUSH BACK.
BUT THAT'LL LET ALONE.
TELUS
WHEN THE INSTITUTION THE
COMMITTEE ITSELF RESPONSIBLE.
FOR PROTECTING OUR EMPLOYEES.
IT'S UNWILLING TO HAVE AN OPEN
AND HONEST DISCUSSION. ABOUT
WHAT ROLE ARE VERY EMPLOYEES
SHOULD PLAY IN THAT PROCESS.
THAT SHOULD ALARM US ALL.
ALL I'M ASKING FOR.
IS WHAT WE ASK EVERY OTHER
EMPLOYER TO DEAL.
TO GIVE THEIR WORKERS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO HAVE THAT PLACE.
I CANNOT IMAGINE THE HEIGHTS OF
HYPOCRISY.
THAT WE PUT OURSELVES THAT AND
WHEN WE SAY WHAT IS GOOD FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE IS NOT GOOD HERE
IN THIS WORKPLACE.
I RESPECT MY STAFF IN THE STAFF
THAT WORK FOR EVERYBODY IN THIS
BUILDING FAR TOO MUCH.
TO BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN NOT
COME TOGETHER AND MAKE A
DECISION FOR THEMSELVES.
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD
HAVE A VOICE WHAT THAT BOY
SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND HOW IF THEY
CHOSE TO THEY COULD COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN. A CONTRACT.
THAT DOES NOT PUT THIS
INSTITUTION IN JEOPARDY.
OUR WORKERS ARE HERE BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE IN WHAT WE DO.
ANY BELIEF.
THAT IS THE RESULT OF THIS BILL
THAT THEY WOULD COME TOGETHER
AND ROOM THIS INSTITUTION.
IS INSULTING.
IT'S INSULTING TO WHAT THEY DO
EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH OUT THOSE
PARTS.
IT'S INSULTING TO WHAT THEY DO
TO KEEP US AN OFFICE.
TO MAKE THE STATE RUN.
AND TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT US.
I AM ASKING TODAY FOR A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY SHOW OUR
EMPLOYEES.
THAT AT LEAST WE RESPECT THEM AS
MUCH AS ANY OTHER CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
PER SECOND.
THANK YOU.
IN WITH THAT MEMBER. OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS A VERY UNIQUE SITUATION
THAT.
WHEN BROUGHT UPON US AS LOOKING
TO SUPPORT OUR STAFF MEMBERS
HERE.
I KNOW WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
OCCURRED SINCE LAST YEAR WITH
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN FOLKS ARE YOU
WORKING NOT SOME LEGISLATION.
TO DROP HELP ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
THAT ANY EMPLOYER SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SPEAK THEIR
CONSCIOUS ON WHAT THEY THINK AND
FEEL. AS FAR AS WORKING IN THIS
BUILDING.
WHICH IS A VERY UNIQUE POSITION
TO PUT A SEN ALWAYS SEE HERE IN
THIS BUILDING.
TO.
.
GIVE THOSE EMPLOYEES THE RIGHTS.
I THINK THAT IN ANY OTHER CASE.
THINGS ARE DIFFERENT BUT WITH
THIS IT'S IT'S A VERY UNIQUE
INSTITUTION RIGHT. A MEMBERS
COME AND GO THE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS
AND I THINK OF THE WAY THE
BUILDING THE STRUCTURE.
AND OUR POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
.
IT COMPOSED OF ISSUES WITH FOLKS
RIGHT.
ABU WITHOUT SAID I SEE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I APPLAUD YOU
FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO.
A FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE.
TO BE THEIR VOICE WHEN NOBODY
ELSE WANTS TO.
AND WITH THAT SAID.
IT'S SOMETHING YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT.
IN TRYING TO DISCUSS OVER THE
WEEKEND OVERSEE.
TIMING WAS ALL SHORT WITH US
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT MORE
QUESTIONS FOR ME MORE LESSON
THAT I KNOW. OTHER MEMBERS AS
WELL HAVE A LOT MORE CONCERNED
TO QUESTIONS AND I THINK.
.
SHORT TIME TO GET EVERYBODY ON
BOARD IS VERY DIFFICULT THIS
ISN'T THE ONLY BILL OBVIOUSLY
THE WERE. A DISCUSSION TODAY.
BUT WITHOUT SAID. ARE OBVIOUSLY
COME FROM A HOUSEHOLD OF UNION
EMPLOYEES AND OUR WORKERS AND. I
MYSELF HAVE HELPED ORGANIZE AND
THEN.
.
MINISTRY AND EMPLOYS COMPANIES
RIGHT.
I DO NOT HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
ON THIS BECAUSE THE FACT THAT I
SEE THAT THERE ARE SOME MORE
QUESTIONS MORE THAN.
CONCERNS AND AND TRYING TO GET
WRAP MYSELF AROUND THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
.
I CAN REALLY UNDERSTAND FOR
HARDLY ABOUT IT.
AND THAT IS WHY AG DIDN'T GIVE A
RECOMMENDATION.
I BELIEVE I CAN GIVE A SECOND TO
THAT MOTION WHICH I WILL.
AND.
.
PUBLIC INTO SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ADDRESS
ISSUES. THAT I SHOULD NOT BE.
S. LEFT TODAY AS IS
AND SHARE THOSE CONCERNS WITH
SOME THE COLLEAGUES BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE THE
NEED TO BE DISCUSSED.
AND I'M ALSO GONNA FIT MAKES IT
TO THE FLOOR RESERVE MY RIGHT TO
SUPPORT IT HOPEFULLY THAT YOU
CAN ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND
MAKE IT MORE CLARIFYING TO A LOT
OF MEMBERS. BECAUSE I THINK
THEY'RE STILL MORE QUESTIONS
THAT NEED TO BE ANSWERED.
SO WITH THAT SECRETARY LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL BECAUSE I THINK
THIS WOULD BE MOVED OUT TO.
APPROPRIATIONS.
YES THE MOTION IS THE PATH I
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
AYE REGUS AYE ALLEN. BROUGH
CERVANTES. CERVANTES AYE COOLEY
COOPER O'DONNELL.
THINK YOU MISTER CHECK.
PROMOTIONS ON CALL.
I THINK WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW IS HERE.
AB THIRTY THIRTY FOR SOME
REMEMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY
PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS THAT
THIS IS THE SUM OF ALL THIRTY
THIRTY FOUR WHICH GIVES.
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
POOR KNOWN AS PER. JURISDICTION
OVER LABOR DISPUTES FOR THE
SUPERVISOR OR A UNIT OF PART BY
MOVING EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS FOR SUPERVISORY. UNIT.
OTHER THE AND AND BE A.
IN CALIFORNIA MOST DISTRICTS ARE
COVERED BY A COMMON COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING STATUTE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT COMING FROM BAY
AREA AND OTHER AREAS THAT WE.
HAVE RESOLVE SUCH DISPUTES AND
AN EFFECTIVE WAY THAT ARE
CONSTITUENCIES EXPECT AND
DESERVE A WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF TRYING OUT IN THE
BACK HALF OF ASKED ME IN CELL
CRUZ A BEHALF.
OF A ASK ME LOCAL. THIRTY NINE
NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU GOD.
IS THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
BRIAN NELSON WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES FIRST I'D
LIKE TO COMMEND THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR HIS.
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS ON THIS
BILL ON I'D ALSO JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL FORD.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THIRTY FOUR
ODD PROVIDES THE GUIDANCE OF AN
ESTABLISHED COMPREHENSIVE LABOR
RELATIONS STATUTE THEM MYERS
MILIUS BROWN ACT OR IN INDIA.
ARE AND A NEUTRAL ADMINISTRATIVE
AGENCY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS BOARD PER. OUGHT TO
RESOLVE UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
ISSUES AND LABOR RELATIONS
DISPUTES.
THERE'S ESTABLISH PRECEDENT BY
THIS BODY.
FOR MOVING THESE WORKERS ON THE
PRESSURES FICTION AS IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE WITH ASSEMBLY
BILL WHILE ONE NINE NINE AT THE
TIME BUT THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR
PAY FOR.
TRANSFERRED LABOR RELATIONS.
THE LABOR RELATIONS SURE
SECTION WERE ROUGHLY FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SUPERVISOR SUPERVISOR EMPLOYEES
AT THE LOS ANGELES.
COUNTY METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
OUGHT DISTRICT.
WITH THIS BILL WE JUST SIMPLY
HOPE TO ESTABLISH A FAIR BALANCE
AND COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH YOU LP'S OR UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICES CONTRACT
DISPUTES AND OTHER ISSUES
BETWEEN LABOR MANAGEMENT.
AND TODAY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT VOTING WITH US WE ALSO
HAVE. OUR THE PRESIDENT FOR MATT
FOR ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
NINETY THREE SOUTH GROUP CREWS
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
IN THE BILL.
THAT MORNING CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS UP PRESIDENT APPS ME
LOCAL THREE NINE NINE THREE SAN
FRANCISCO BART SUPERVISED
PROFESSIONAL UNION.
EVERY FOUR YEARS.
THE.
DURING OUR CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS
EITHER BART OR THE BARTLEY
REUNIONS COME TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND SEEK YOUR GUIDANCE AND HELP.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP US RESOLVE
THE ONGOING STRUCTURAL DISPUTES
THAT WE HAVE SO THAT IT'S LESS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN.
OUR ORIGINAL STATUTE WAS.
CREATED IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN
LAST MODIFIED NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE THE LABOR RELATIONS STATUTE
THAT GOVERNS US. TO THE REAL
REALLY ISN'T MUCH THERE THAT
ASSISTANCE DURING CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS OR THE DISPUTES
ARISE IN BETWEEN.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL BE A
HELP US MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IMPROVING BOTH LABOR
RELATIONS FOR BOTH THE EMPLOYER
BART AND THE SUPERVISORY UNION.
THEY'LL HELP US RESOLVE MULTIPLE
ISSUES ON BARGAINING GOOD FAITH
OF REPRESENTATION DISPUTES AND
THE WRIT RESOLUTION OF UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICES. SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE SPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN
BAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS REPRESENTING
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT. THE BART BOARD
OF DIRECTORS JUST OPEN OPPOSE
POSITION TO THE BILL ON THURSDAY
OF LAST WEEK AND WE'RE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE OUR LETTER TO THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS JUST THIS
WEEK. I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE A
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER FOR
ADMINISTRATION AT PART MICHAEL
JONES AND CHIEF LABOR RELATIONS
OFFICER MARTIN GRANT.
TO SPEAK MORE ON THE BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
JONES ON THE ASSISTANT GENERAL
MANAGER OF ADMINISTRATION AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT.
BART HAS ADOPTED AN OPPOSE
POSITION ON ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
ZERO THREE FOUR.
WE BELIEVE A LOCAL SOLUTION TO
OUR EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
IS PREFERABLE TO THIS BILL WHICH
AS WRITTEN WILL RESULT IN LOSS
OF LOCAL CONTROL FOR BOTH THE
BARDEN PLOY ORGANIZATIONS. AS
WELL AS THE BARD MORT OF
DIRECTORS.
THIS BILL WAS VERY RECENTLY GUT
AND AMEND IT WITH NO PRIOR
NOTIFICATION TO THE BART BOARD
OF DIRECTORS NOR BART MANAGEMENT
WHICH LEFT US WITH VERY LITTLE
TIME TO DISCUSS ANY ISSUES WITH
ASKED ME.
WE FEEL STRONGLY THAT OUR LABOR
RELATIONS ISSUES ARE BEST
ADDRESSED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BAR AND ITS LABOR UNIONS HAVE
RECENTLY DEMONSTRATED ITS
ABILITY TO CONSTRUCTIVELY A
COLLABORATIVE WE NEGOTIATE
ISSUES.
BY AGREEING TO CONTRACT
EXTENSIONS IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THAT LAST UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
AND JUST LAST MONTH WE REACHED
AN AGREEMENT CLARIFYING CERTAIN
SPECIAL PAY PROVISIONS IN THE
UNION'S CBA. A WHICH RESULTED
AND REPORTABLE COMPENSATION TO
CALPERS.
ALSO THE BART BOARD OF DIRECTORS
HAS CLEARLY EXPRESSED ITS
WILLINGNESS TO RESOLVE ANY OF
THE ISSUES.
I ASKED ME HOUSE.
OUR BOARD HAS SCHEDULED A CLOSED
DOOR SESSION IN ITS NEXT NEXT
WEEK WEEKS MEETING TO ADDRESS
LABOR MANAGEMENT ISSUES AND A
FUTURE MEETING. OF THE BOARD
BOARD LABOR NEGOTIATIONS SPECIAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL OCCUR AS
WELL.
AB THREE ZERO THREE FOUR WOULD
HAVE NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON PART BY
POTENTIALLY DELAYING
FACILITATION AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF ESSENTIAL PROJECTS.
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY CONCERN.
NUMBER ONE THE MYERS MILIUS
BROWN ACT WOULD REQUIRE FACT
FINDING ON DISPUTED ISSUES
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF BARGAINING
WHICH INCLUDES SINGLE ISSUE
DISPUTES.
WE WOULD BE PREVENTED FROM
NECESSARY UNILATERAL CHANGES TO
WORKING CONDITIONS PRIOR TO
ENGAGING IN THAT FACT FINDING
PROCESS.
A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE A POTENTIAL
ADVERSE IMPACTS ARE AS FOLLOWS
NUMBER ONE THE DISTRICT HAS THEY
EXISTING CLASSIFICATION TITLED
OPERATION SUPERVISOR LIAISON.
ONE OF THE PRIMARY FUNCTIONS OF
THIS CLASSIFICATION IS TO
PERFORM SAFETY MONITORING FOR
WORK BEING DONE ON THE RAILROAD.
WE RECENTLY BARGAIN SUCCESSFULLY
WITH ASKED ME TO MODIFY WORKING
CONDITIONS WHICH ALLOW THE
DISTRICT TO HIRE AND OR PROMOTE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY NEW
EMPLOYEES INTO THIS CLASS.
HOWEVER IF WE WERE UNDER THE M.
MBA. THE BARGAINING UNIT COULD
HAVE DISPUTED ANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE BARGAIN. AND THEY COULD
HAVE DELAYED THE HIGHER OF THOSE
NEEDED ADDITIONAL PEOPLE OUGHT
TO SAFELY RUN CONSTRUCTION
OPERATIONS ON THE ROAD.
AND WE WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN TO PREVENT IT
FROM MOVING FORWARD UNTIL THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BORE.
OUT WOULD HAVE COMPLETED THE
FACT FINDING WHICH WOULD HAVE
DELAYED THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ENHANCEMENTS.
CURRENTLY BART HAS APPROXIMATELY
THREE STE THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OF HOME.
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED ARE
REPRESENTED BY ONE OF OUR FIVE
UNIONS.
FOUR OF THE FIVE UNIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE GOVERNED UNDER
THE BARD ACT WHILE ONE OF THE
UNITS OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES. WHAT POTENTIALLY BE
GOVERNED BY AN MBA FROM MID
CONTRACT DISPUTES?
AND UNDER THE BARD ACT AND THE
M. MBA DURING CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS AN
UNNECESSARY OVERLAY TO EXISTING
OPERATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY UNDER THIS BILL
BART LABOR COMPLIANCE COSTS
COULD ESCALATE BY AS MUCH AS
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
FOR THIS REASON BAR OPPOSES AB
THREE ZERO THREE FOUR AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NOVO.
THANK YOU MISTER.
ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
BUT IN QUESTION LIKE MANY
MEMBERS.
SO WITH THAT SAID HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE CLUBS CROPS ARE.
THANKS FOR MOTIONS OUR MOTION.
SECOND.
SO WITH THAT WHICH ELECT CLIPS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID I WANT TO
A STATE OF FOR THE RECORD AS
WELL THAT WE ARE A COMMITTED TO
ENGAGING WITH CONTINUE DIALOGUE
AND STAKEHOLDERS. ACTUALLY
TODAY.
AS THOUGH WE WANT TO CONSIDER
FOSTER THESE. CONVERSATIONS IN
THE SPIRIT OF ENSURING THAT WE
FINALLY ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
OUR AT THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN
WITH RESPECT TO ASK FOR AB.
THANK YOU WITH THAT IN WITH THAT
I DO HAVE A HIGH RECOMMENDATION
ON THIS IS WELL AND I LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE WORK OPPOSITION
ADDRESS SOME ISSUES. SO THAT
SECRETARY LIKE COLOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ I ALLEN. BROUGH
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY. COOPER
O'DONNELL.
THE ALBION COLLEGE WE HAVE A
BRING BACK THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO WITH THAT SAID WE HAVE NO
OTHER MEMBERS IN THE IN THE ROOM
AS WE SPEAK. I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND PRESENT ON MY BILL AB
NINETEEN TWELVE LACKS THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAVANT IS PRETTY
TAKE OVER BUT PRIOR TO THAT.
JUST BEEN INFORMED THAT MY BILL
A. B..
AB NINETEEN TWELVE THE COULD BE
AN ERROR IN ONE OF THE REPORTS
ALL HAVE STAFF LOOK INTO IT. EN.
REVISED IT IF THE AIR IS FOUND
SUCH ONE TO MAKE THAT STATEMENT
FORGOTTEN PRESENTED THE BILL SO
THAT
.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWELVE
LAST YEAR CALPERS REDUCE THE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS
OF ALMOST TWO HUNDRED EMPLOYEES.
OF THE EAST SIDE YOU'RE A VALLEY
HUMAN SERVICES CONSORTIUM AT AJP
A. AFTER ITS SOURCE OF REVENUE
WAS TERMINATED.
THE JPA TERMINATE ALL OF ITS
EMPLOYEES WAS A NEIGHBOR PAGE
RETIREMENT OBLIGATIONS DUE TO
CALPERS AND BECAME INSOLVENT.
IN RESPONSE TO CALPERS DEMAND
FOR PAYMENT OF THE JP EIGHT
OBLIGATIONS.
THE CITIES OF AZUSA COVINA
GLENDORA WEST COVINA THAT
CREATED THE JPA MAINTAINED THAT
THEY WERE NOT RESPONSIBLE.
SINCE PAYMENT FOR THE JP HAYES
OBLIGATIONS.
COULD BE OBTAINED FROM THE JP OR
CITIES AND WITHOUT NECESSARILY
THIRTY. CALPERS WAS FORCED
REDUCE THOSE JP RETIREES
BENEFITS BY SIXTY THREE PERCENT.
IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR WE
DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE DURING A
JOINT HEARING OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE SENATE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE.
THERE ARE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY OTHER JP EIGHT THAT
CURRENTLY CONTRACT WITH CALPERS.
AND NUMEROUS OTHER OUTSIDE OF
CALPERS WHERE THIS ISSUE COULD
HAPPEN AGAIN.
AB NINETEEN TWELVE WILL PROVIDE
RETIREMENT SECURITY TO JP HAYES
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES BY
REQUIRING JOINT AND SEVERAL
LIABILITY PROVISIONS IN
CONTRACTS.
BETWEEN J. P. A.'S AND
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS.
I'VE MET WITH SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS TO HEAR THEIR CONCERNS
AND WILL BE AMENDED THE BILL
TOWARDS REACHING COMMON GROUND.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE DISCUSSED IN
PAGE THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN OF
THE NOW LOSSES.
WITH ME TODAY IS TERRY.
PREGNANT OF SL YOU AND SANDY
MESA WHO IS AFFECTED RETIREE OF
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY JPA AND
OTHERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TERRY
BRENNAN ON BEHALF S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA I LET ME APOLOGIZE
FIRST THAT.
SANDY MAYES SAYS NOT HERE USE
ONE OF THE TWO HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
WHO HAD HER.
RETIREMENT REDUCED BY.
TO TO ONLY SIXTY PERCENT OF THE
EXPECTED LEVEL SHE'S FOUND
EMPLOYMENT WAS UNABLE TO JOIN
US.
.
BECAUSE OF HER HER NEW JOB.
AND THE CHAIR.
RIGHTFULLY POINTED OUT THIS CAME
OUT OF A JOINT HEARING.
BETWEEN THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
WHO ED WE HAVE BEEN MEETING
WITH OUR OPPOSITION THAT LEAGUE
CITIES AND THE COUNTIES IN THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS?
IN THE INTERVENING TIME TO TALK
ABOUT.
I HOW TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
EVERYONE IN THOSE MEETINGS
EXPRESSED. A DESIRE TO MAKE SURE
THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
HOWEVER THE OPPOSITION'S BAND
RELUCTANT.
TO LOOK BACK AT THOSE AGENCIES
THAT ARE ALREADY MEMBERS OF
CALPERS THOSE JP HAYES.
THAT ARE ALREADY CONTRACTING
WITH CALPERS WHICH LEADS.
TO SOME NEAR HUNDRED SEVENTY JP
HAYES AND SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
TWENTY AND THIRTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES. AT RISK OF THE SAME
FATE AS HE SANK APRIL EMPLOYEES.
THE CHAIRS BILL HAS.
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS THIS AND I
WANT TO SPEAK TO A COUPLE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT CAME OUT OF
THIS.
ONE.
WAYS TO CLEARLY DEFINE DEFINE
THE OBLIGATIONS.
THAT ARE LIABLE FOR HERE IS ONLY
THE PENSION OBLIGATIONS OF THE
EMPLOYEES NOT ALL THE
OBLIGATIONS OF THE JPA MIGHT
ENCUMBER OVER TIME.
WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES ANY
POTENTIAL OBLIGATION TO THE.
COLLECTIVE OF MEMBERS OF THE
JPA AND.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
REFRESH MY MEMORY MITCH BOLDEN.
PLEASE.
APPORTIONMENT YES WHICH IS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. IF YOU HAVE.
TEN TWELVE FIFTEEN MEMBERS OF
THE JPA THEY SHOULDN'T ALL
REPORT THE ENTIRE LIABILITY SO
THAT'S REPORTED FIFTEEN FOLD
UNDER GAS BE.
BUT LIKE AGENCIES CURRENTLY.
CONTRACTING WITH CALPERS YOU CAN
APPORTION THE LIABILITY AMOUNT
AND THEREFORE GIVE A FAIR
ASSESSMENT AS LONG AS THAT
EQUALS A HUNDRED PERCENT.
AND CALPERS HAS THE ABILITY TO
GO BACK AND GET IT.
AND FOR THAT REASON AND.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
RESOLVE ANY ISSUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DOCILE GOKU WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT.
A CENTER PEROT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
BUT CHEN MEMBERS PACMAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIA
SUCH AS ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS AND
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WELL.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED AS ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS MEASURE.
MAX VERY CITY OF SAN CARLOS NOT
POSITION.
YOU WANT YOUR MEMBERS STAINED
HUTCHINS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE
WHILE WELL INTENDED AB NINETEEN
TWELVE PLACES SIGNIFICANT BURDEN
ON LOCAL AGENCIES THAT. I IF
ENACTED WOULD EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATE A PUBLIC AGENCIES
ABILITY DELIGHTS GPAS FOR
REGIONAL SERVICES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AB NINETEEN TWELVE
WOULD APPLY RETROACTIVELY AS
WELL AS PROACTIVE PERSPECTIVE
JOINED SEVERAL LIABILITY FOR ALL
RETIREMENT RELATED OBLIGATIONS.
FOR CURRENT AND FORMER JPA
MEMBER SINCE SINCE THE INCEPTION
OF THAT JPA.
SUCH AJ OBLIGATIONS INCLUDE
ACTIVE EMPLOYEE NORMAL COST
PENSIONS RETIREE UNFUNDED
ACCRUED LIABILITIES AS WELL AS
BOTH ACTIVE RETIREE HEALTH CARE
AND OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THAT DOT THE
INTENT OF THE AUTHOR IS TO LIMIT
THE SCOPE OF THE BELL TO
RETIREMENT LIABILITIES ONLY BUT
WE CANNOT OVERSTATE THE FACT
THAT. RETIREMENT LIABILITIES
ACCOUNT FOR IN THE STATE
CURRENTLY A CHILDREN FORTY ONE
BILLION FOR PENSION PLANS AND A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE BILLION FOR
RETIREE HEALTHCARE COSTS SO IT
IS NOT CERTAIN A SMALL NUMBER.
SO MEASURE ALSO MANDATE THAT
DEBATE THAT ANY CALIFORNIA BASE
RETIREMENT AGENCIES TO EACH
AGENCY WHO HAS ENTERED INTO A
GPA.
FOR ALL RELATED RETIREMENT COST
PLUS ATTORNEY'S FEES.
GP'S ARE STRUCTURALLY
INDEPENDENT GOVERNING BODIES WHO
MAKE HIRING DECISIONS QUICKLY
BARGAIN INTO CONTRACTS ON THEIR
OWN ACCORD. INTO MY BRICK TO
ACTIVELY APPLYING DEBTS AND
LIABILITIES TO EACH AGENCY WHO
ENTERS INTO A GPA THERE ARE
MAJOR CONCERNS THAT FOR SMALLER
AGENCIES AB MAKING TROUBLE PUT
THEM IN CONFLICT WITH ARTICLE
SIXTEEN. SUBSECTION MAKING THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THAT
PROHIBITS AN AGENCY FROM
OCCURRING DEBTS AND LIABILITIES.
THAT EXCEED THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUES THAT THEY GET MEDICARE
WITHOUT ABOUT OF THE PEOPLE TO
CENTURY LIKE IT'S SHOWING A
BOND.
WITHOUT THAT WITHOUT A VOTE
FURTHER CAN BE ARGUED THAT THIS
BILL FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES WOULD
VIOLATE ARTICLE SIXTEEN SECTION
SIX OF THE CONSTITUTION. WHICH
PROHIBITS ANY AGENCY FOR GIVING
OR LENDING PUBLIC FUNDS TO ANY
PERSON.
AB NINETEEN TWELVE ALSO
ESTABLISHES AYE OPERATIONAL
PAYMENTS AFTER THE GAS THE BOARD
ARE REPORTING LIABILITIES.
DE ANALYSIS AT NOTES THAT.
REPORTING LIABILITIES WOULD.
ONLY BE.
ON A PORTION BASIS ARE HOWEVER
JOINED SEVERAL LIABILITIES THAT.
EXCUSE ME.
OAK OAK.
I I CAN AT ABSOLUTELY NO OTHER
FOLKS WERE GIVEN A LOT MORE TIME
BUT THAT'S THAT'S FINE I'LL LOOK
AT AND CONTINUE.
.
SO WE AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE SPONSORS THAT WHAT HAPPENED
LA WORK SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN
AGAIN FORTUNATE THIS APPROACH IS
ON HELP RETIREES OF LA WORKS. IT
IS NOT SOLVE ITCH PROPERTIES
FUTURE GPAS ARE AT RISK AND IS
OUR HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK FOR
THE SPONSORS AND RETIREMENT
AGENCIES IN AN ALTERNATIVE
APPROACH. A.
THANK YOU.
BUT CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DILLON GIVENS WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LEVY CITIES AND WE HOPE THAT
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE PITCH OF
THE EMPLOYEES AT THE.
RETIREES HAVE THAT YOU SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY HUMAN SERVICES
CONSORTIUM.
WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ONLY WITH
THIS LEGISLATION NOT ASSIST
THOSE EMPLOYEES AFTER THE FACT.
BUT HAD THIS BEEN IN PLACE
PRIOR TO TO THEIR DISSOLUTION.
THE OUTCOME WOULD HAVE LIKELY
BEEN THE SAME A ADDITIONALLY AB
NINETEEN TWELVE.
WOULD RESULT IN EVEN MORE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES HAVING THE
PENSIONS REDUCED
AND LET'S LET ME WALK YOU
THROUGH IT HOW HOW THAT WOULD
HAPPEN USING.
EASTING GABRIEL'S EXAMPLE UNDER
A. B. NINETEEN TWELVE.
SO UNDER THIS LEGISLATION.
THE GPA IN THAT THE MEMBER
AGENCIESWOULD HAVE GOTTEN
TOGETHER TO SEE IF THE MEMBER
AGENCIES ARE WILLING TO DIVIDE
UP THE PROPORTIONAL LIABILITY
FOR THE NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN A CRUDE LIABILITY THE JPA THE
FOR CITIES OF THE COUNTY WOULD
LIKE WE SAID NO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO TAKE THAT LEVEL OF.
OF RISKING GREAT LIE BILLY FROM
JPA THAT'S COMPLETELY FUNDED BY
A GRANT FUNDS.
CALPERS WOULD HAVE.
THINK GIVEN THE JPA THE OPTION
OF PAYING THE NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO TERMINATE THE
CONTRACT OR AMEND THE CONTRACT
YOU SIGNED THE LIABILITY.
UNFORTUNATELY WHILE CALPERS CAN
AMEND THE CONTRACT WITH GPA.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
AMEND THE CONTRACT YOU SIGNED
THE LIABILITIES MEMBER AGENCIES
WHICH ARE NOT PARTY TO THE
CONTRACT.
I THE JPA WOULD THEN BE ON THE
HOOK FOR THE IMMEDIATE PAYMENT
OF THE TERMINATED AGENCY POOL OF
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
DID YOU KNOW THEY COULDN'T PAY
AND THE CONTRACT WAS TERMINATED
WITH A WITH A GPA AND THE JP WAS
DISSOLVED.
THEN CALPERS AS A RESULT OF THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD HAVE NO
ALTERNATIVE BUT TO TERMINATE THE
CONTRACT REDUCE THAT PENSION
BENEFITS.
OF THE A HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES AND SUE
THE MEMBER AGENCIES TO TRY TO
RECOVER THE MONEY.
THE MEMBER AGENCIES WHO OF WITH
THAT WITH THE LAWSUIT BECAUSE
THEY NEVER AGREED TO ACCEPT A
LIABILITY FOR THE EMPLOYEES THAT
WERE NOT THEIRS.
THE OUTCOME IS THE EXACT SAME
ONLY CALPERS HAS LESS OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM TO REDUCE THE
EMPLOYEE PENSIONS A THAT PITCHER
REDUCTIONS.
NOW IF WE APPLY THAT NINETEEN
TWELVE TO EVERY GPA INSTEAD OF
IT ENSURING THE PENSION OF GPA
EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL PUTS THEIR PENSIONS AT
GREATER RISK.
WHEN MEMBER AGENCIES WERE NEVER
PART OF THE CONTRACT CALPERS
REFUSED TO ACCEPT THE LIABILITY
FOR THE EMPLOYEES.
THAT YOU THEY DO NOT MANAGE OR
NEGOTIATE OVER THEIR BENEFIT
LEVELS GPAS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WILL BE FORCED TO SHUT DOWN.
WHEN THEY RECEIVE IN THE
ENORMOUS BILL FROM CALPERS WITH
THE FORCED TERMINATION OF THEIR
CONTRACTS.
THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN
UNNECESSARY REDUCTION IN PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE PENSIONS AND REDUCTION
OF SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC. FOR
THESE REASONS REST FOR YOU KNOW
VOTE.
MADAM CHAIR ANTHONY CAN SOLVE US
I REPRESENT VARIOUS CITIES THAT
ARE OPPOSED TO THE SPELL.
I HAPPEN TO ACTUALLY DO SOME
WORK FOR LA WORKS.
AND THERE WAS AN UNFORTUNATE
INCIDENT CAT.
THERE WAS A NONPROFIT NOW LAKE
COUNTY THAT WAS CAUGHT DOING
FRAUD.
WITH THEIR BILLINGS WITH THE LA
COUNTY.
UNFORTUNATELY LA WORKS ACTUALLY
DID.
A ACCOUNTING AIR.
AND WE HELPED SET P MEETINGS
WITH SOME OF THE SUPERVISORS
THAT BE ABLE TO FIX THAT
ACCOUNTING THERE. BUT ONE
SUPERVISOR WAS VERY CLOSE
TO THIS NONPROFIT THAT LOST
THEIR CONTRACT.
AND THAT SUPERVISOR INSISTED.
BET THEY PUNISH LA WORKS IT WAS
A POLITICAL MOVE IT WAS THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS THAT LA WORKS WAS AN
OPERATION OF ONE ALL THESE
AWARDS TAKING CARE OF
DISADVANTAGED CHILDREN. AND
KIDS.
GIVING THEM THE GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL. TRAIN THE SHERIFF
DEPARTMENT AND DON'T A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS AND LA COUNTY
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE COUNTY.
AND BECAUSE OF A POLITICAL MOVE
THEY PUT LA WORKS OUT OF
BUSINESS.
EVEN THOUGH THE UNION.
THE EMPLOYEES.
SHOWED UP AT THE BOARD MEETING
SAID OUR JOBS ARE ON THE LINE.
THAT'S THE ONLY INCIDENT I KNOW
OF IN THE STATE AND. WE'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
THE TRY AND NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL. BUT THERE'S NO OTHER
JPA THAT I'M.
AWARE OF THAT HAS HAD THIS
PROBLEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
YES GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DOROTHY JOHNSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND ALSO BEHALF MY
COLLEAGUE WITH URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
WARNING THAT IN SHARING CHAIR
MEMBERS JOHN HILLY FIRE CHIEF
FOR THE CITY OF SAN MATEO
BELMONT IN FOSTER CITY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
AND RED SMOKE HUMAN RESOURCES
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF FOSTER
CITY REPRESENTING BELMONT AND
SAN MATEO AS WELL IN OPPOSITION.
DAVID JONES BEHALF THAT CITIES
OF BURBANK SAN MARCOS AND
MARIETTA AND OPPOSITION.
FAVORING BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF A
JOINT POWER AUTHORITIES WE SHARE
THE CONCERNS THAT WHERE I HADN'T
CONVEYED BY THE LEAGUE AND THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORED HAVE STAFF. MOVING FOR
IT.
GOOD MORNING KIRK BLACKBURN ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOCKING
OUT OF FLINTRIDGE IN OPPOSITION.
ANNA GRANDIS ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN THE CITY OF
INDIAN WELLS IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOK
REVERSING ON THE CALIFORNIA
POWER AGENCY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF MISTER
CHAIR THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
I HAVE THE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WE ASK FOR AN AUDIT LAST YEAR.
OF THE WASTE WATER AUTHORITY IN
MY DISTRICT AND.
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT CAME
BACK SAYING BUT THAT THERE WAS A
LEGISLATIVE REMEDY NEEDED
BECAUSE THERE WAS EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITIES AND THE
MEMBER AGENCIES WEREN'T
RESPONSIBLE.
SO THERE DEFINITELY IS A NEED
FOR.
SOME LEGISLATIVE ACTION HERE
BUT.
I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO A COUPLE
MORE COMMITTEES.
I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY BUT I
THINK YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT PATH
HOPEFULLY YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION I KNOW
WE'VE GOT I THINK TO MORE
COMMITTEES BEFORE AGAINST THE
FLOOR. BUT I I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR BEING IS FOR BECAUSE
THERE IS IT THERE'S AN ISSUE
HERE. BUT.
I JUST HOPE YOU ALL WILL
CONTINUE UP THE OPPOSITION TO
MAKE THIS ABOUT A BILL THANK.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COURSE.
WELL I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR HIS COMMENTS JUST
NOW IN THE AUDIT ISSUE.
I DO THINK THIS IS A.
A TOUGH ISSUE.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME IT BECOMES
IMPORTANT HAVE RULES IN PLACE IS
SORT OF IN FORCE.
FISCAL DISCIPLINE.
IN THESE GPAS IN THE CONDUCT
THEIR AFFAIRS.
.
AND.
YOU KNOW IN MY EXPERIENCE YOU
KNOW YOU SEE THESE COULD
ESTABLISH YOU GET MEMBERS OF A
OF A LOCAL UNIT TO GETS THE JOB
ASSUME THE JPA THEY GO THERE
IT'S SORT OF SECONDARY. TO THEIR
PRIMARY DUTIES AGAIN JUST NOD
THEIR HEAD.
APPROVED VARIOUS TYPES OF
CONTRACTS AND AGREEMENTS AND
PLYMOUTH SORTS OF THINGS.
I THINK.
ALL THESE ROLES ARE IMPORTANT TO
TAKE THE SAME SENSE OF FISCAL
DISCIPLINE EVERY ROLE YOU ARE
AND SO I. I FEEL THIS BILL KIND
ACTION REINFORCES THAT.
BY MAKING CLEAR THAT THE
OBLIGATIONS UNDERTAKEN BY THE
JPA.
WHICH WE NEVER GOT PARTICIPATES
IN OUR SORT OF ON THAT UNIV
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I THINK.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL.
IT.
IN THE LARGER SCALE THINGS
SUPPORTS ARE HEALTHY.
PENSION SYSTEM THAT SORT OF
THING BY MAKING SURE THAT THE
COSTS ARE COUNTED FOR. AND
CONSIDERED THE FRONT END.
EVEN IN THESE.
SPECIALIZED UNITS OF
GOVERNMENT SO I. AM SUPPORTING
THE BILL AND I JUST WALKED IN OF
HAS BEEN MOVED OUT OF THE.
BUT THE AUTHOR LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT LAST FOREVER THINKING.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION. AND A
SECOND IF WE.
SECRETARY COMPLETES HOW THE
ROAD.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. RODRIGUEZ.
BUT.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
ROW.
CERVANTES.
FIVE.
COOLEY HIGH.
COOLEY AYE COOPER BY.
COOPER I O'DONNELL TYPE
O'DONNELL AYE.
THE BILL IS ON CALL
SO MEMBERS WHAT WE DO HAVE A.
QUORUM ONE GOING TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
FILE ITEM NUMBER IS OUR MOTION
AND PSYCHO. BACK
MOTION SECOND ON THE FLOOR ON
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY ONE I SIX
COOPER. AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN A. B. THIRTY TO FORTY
FIVE FIRST COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY LIKE KALRA.
RODRIGUEZ.
BY.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
BRO.
BRO I CERVANTES.
TREMENDOUS AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER WILL BE GOING
ON THERE OF CONSENT CALENDAR.
HOW DOES THE COOPER BILL ON THE?
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I THINK HE.
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT AND I
KNOW WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY WHICH LIKE COMING PRESENT.
A SO WE HAVE AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY SIX ALSO INHERITED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IS MY FIRST TIME IN RONT OF
THIS COMMITTEE IT SIR.
HONORED TO BE HERE WITH YOU.
THIS BILL.
PLACES SPECIFIED PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES UNDER THE JURISDICTION
OF THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADJUDICATING UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE DISPUTES.
GOING TO COURT TO RESOLVE LABOR
PRACTICE DISPUTES CAN BE BOTH
TIME CONSUMING AND COSTLY AS WE
ALL KNOW.
BY CONTRAST PERVS EXPERTISE IN
LABOR LAW PROVIDES AN
EXPEDITIOUS AND COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE.
TO ADJUDICATING LABOR DISPUTES
THIS BILL THEREFORE THIS BILL
WILL SAVE TIME AND MONEY.
THE TRANSIT AGENCY EMPLOYER
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES BY
AUTHORIZING THEM TO SEEK
RESOLUTION THROUGH PER.
WITH ME TODAY IS VERY BROAD
REPRESENTING THE TEAMSTERS WHO
WILL SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
OF MAKING LOT YET MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ACTIVE
ACTUALLY. HEARD SEVERAL BILLS
TODAY ON THE SAME THEME OF
MOVING PUBLIC COMPLACENT
REMAINING PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
UNDER PURPOSE JURISDICTION AND.
SO I WON'T REPEAT THOSE
ARGUMENTS I'M I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS THAT REPRESENTS
EMPLOYEES. UP.
CTA IN ORANGE COUNTY AND THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
REPRESENTS EMPLOYEES AT IN THIS
AT. IN STOCKTON SAN JOAQUIN
TRANSIT AGENCY.
AND WE WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THINK ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
THERE'S A MOTION SECOND TO ANY
QUESTION BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
CHUCK CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I APPRECIATE TO YOUR
RECOMMENDATION ON THE BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT I DO HAVE ON
IRAQ ON THIS AND THERE'S MOTION
SECOND.
SECRETARY LIKE CALDERON.
IN THE MARCHES DE PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
GROW. GROW AYE CERVANTES
THURMOND TO SAY COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THE BILL IS THINKING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU
.
YEAH WITHOUT SOME REMEMBER
COOPER
LIKE PRESENT ON A. B. NINETEEN
SIXTEEN COURT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSON
AB NINETEEN SIXTEEN.
WILL HELP CLOSE THE GENDER AND
ETHNICITY PAY GAP.
WITH UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES AND STATE
CIVIL SERVICE CLASSIFICATIONS.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB FORTY SIX
WHICH IS MEN ARE PIC WE LOST TO.
EXCUSE ME
THE PUBLIC SECTOR
HOWEVER RACIAL ETHNIC P.
DISPARITIES REMAIN AN ISSUE. A
TWENTY THIRTEEN STUDY SHOWS
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
HISPANIC WOMEN AND JUST SIXTY
FOUR AND FORTY FOUR CENTS.
RESPECTFULLY FOR EVERY DOLLAR A
WHITE MAN EARNS ADDITIONALLY
AFTER AMERICAN MEN AND SEVEN
FIVE PERCENT.
OF THE AVERAGE SALARY OF WHITE
MEN. AB NINETEEN SIXTEEN REQUIRE
STATE AGAINST THE DEPARTMENTS.
VERY DETAILED REPORT ON GENDER
ETHNIC ETHNICITY WAGE DISPARITY
ANY OTHER REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES.
ITS DEPARTMENTS PLAN SHOULD BE
REPORTED ANNUALLY TO THE
APPROPRIATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
AND MUST INCLUDE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE STATE AGENCIES
PROGRESS FOR RAGE PARITY ANY
DETAILED TIME LINE FOR MEETING
THE GOAL OF WAGE PARITY. AND
RECRUITING ATTRACTING
RETAINING WOMEN MINORITIES.
MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL HOLD A
PUBLIC ISSUE.
RESPECT WE HAVE THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IN ONE SPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RICH JOSH WILL GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS AND
BARGAINING UNIT SIXTEEN AND
NINETEEN WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PET RIGHT
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THAT
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORTERS
MEASURE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MUCH.
SEEINGNONE ANY QUESTION OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BROKE YOUR
QUESTIONS CHAIR ABOUT THIS
COOPER A BUSINESS INCLUDE THE
LEGISLATURE.
IS THE DEATH.
GREAT.
FINALLY.
WITH THAT SAID DUH SOME REMOTE
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THE MOTION HAS BEEN.
MOTION AND SECOND IT WITHOUT
YOU HAVE I REQUEST THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BORN BILL FORD
WITH THAT SECRETARY LIKE
CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
BRO.
WELL I CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
I HOPE FOR
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT MEASURES UP.
I KNOW WE HAVE ONE MORE MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVING JUST WAIT
FOR HIM.
OKAY
.
SO MEMBERS ARE GONNA VOID LEFT
THE CALL IN SOME OF THE THE
BILL'S BEEN PRESENTED WILL START
AND FILE ITEM.
TRANSIT
WHAT WHAT NUMBERS THAT WHAT
FOLLOWED A MOMENT AGO.
YOU HAVE DIFFICULT.
WHAT DOES?
BUT WE STILL HAVEN'T.
WE ARE MISSING MEMBERS.
SO THAT MEMBERS ARE GONNA GO
AHEAD TO A FIVE NUMBER ONE A. B.
NINETEEN TWELVE A SECRETARY LIKE
TO CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN SNYDER OKAY.
THEY.
BUT ABOUT NUMBER TWO AB NINETEEN
SIXTY COOPER.
CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS
ALLEN.
THE BILL IS OUT IN WITH THAT
BEFORE GOING FURTHER I KNOW WE
I MEAN HERE WOULD YOU GO AHEAD
AND.
GOING PRESENTS A WHILE YOU'RE
HERE THANK YOU.
IF YOU HAVE A BE THIRTY EIGHTY
FOUR SO WHEN YOU'RE GOING. TO
LOVE IT MORE LIKE AN ORDER THAT
AN INVITATION CYCLE YOU PRESENT
ALREADY A HOOK BAKER I KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE HAD A BIG MORNING.
AND CYPRESS SHAPE THIS SITE
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING THE PRESENT AB THIRTY
EIGHTY FOR THE BILL REQUIRES THE
GOVERNING BODY. OF A PUBLIC
AGENCY TO SHOW THAT IT HAS MET
SPECIFIED PARAMETERS RELATED TO
THE PROVISION OF OTHER POST
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ITS ANNUAL
FINANCE STATEMENT SUBMITTED TO
THE STATE COMPTROLLER.
ON JANUARY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN STATE CONTROLLER BUT HE
NOTED THE FOLLOWING. UNDER NEW
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS CREATED BY
THE GOVERNMENTAL ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS BOARD THE STATE'S
COSTS FOR RETIREE HEALTH AND
DENTAL BENEFITS HAS GONE TO
NINETY ONE POINT FIVE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. THE LIABILITY
REPRESENTS THE PRESENT DAY COST
TO PROVIDE HEALTH AND DENTAL
BENEFITS TO STATE RETIREES AND
THEIR DEPENDENTS EARNED AS OF
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
ONE OF THE STATE'S LARGEST LONG
TERM DEBTS.
AS CONTROL ARE YOU FURTHER STATE
OF YOUR PET LIABILITY WILL BE
UNPREDICTABLE AND WILL REMAIN A
PARAMOUNT FISCAL CHALLENGE OVER
THE NEXT THREE DECADES.
THIS ACCOUNTABILITY BILLS A
SMALL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TOWARD GETTING OUR
FISCAL HOUSE IN ORDER. ON THIS
PRESSING ISSUE WHICH WE HAVE TO
TAKE MORE SERIOUSLY IN THE NEAR
TERM. THANK YOU ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE WHO THE BILL THANK.
THE BILL'S BEEN NOT MOTION
SECOND WITH THAT ANYONE IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
A CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
DEALING GIVE IS THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WE
DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL. BUT WE DO HAVE.
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE REPORTING
IN AND THE WAY THEY MAY BE
RECEIVED.
OPEC FUNDING IS OBVIOUSLY A
VERY BIG DEAL AND AND AND THAT
HUGE COST TO OUR MEMBERS. AND
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES AS A WHOLE.
HOWEVER THE PRE FUNDING OF
VOEPEL OBLIGATIONS IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT.
AND THERE ARE MANY AGENCIES WHO
CANNOT AFFORD TO PRE FUND THOSE
OBLIGATIONS.
AS RESULT OF NOT HAVING THE
ASSETS TO PAY THOSE THAT COULD
BE YEAH THEY CAN BE CONSTRUED AS
NOT ACTING ON BEHALF OF THOSE
WHO. JUST WANT YOUR THOSE
CONCERNS WE DO NOT HAVE WE'RE
NOT OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION
AT THIS TIME THANK.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING ON.
ANY QUESTION BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBER
LIKE CLOSE.
OUR CHEF BASS FOR MY VOTE.
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND I DO HAVE I RECALL ON
THIS THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD A SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
WROTE.
BRUNO CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER. COOPER AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THANK YOU THE MEASURES UP THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE HAVE A GREAT DAY THINKS.
SO MEMBERS ARE GONNA GO BACK TO
FILE ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
OR BACK TO FOLLOW ITEM NUMBER
THREE SECRETARY LIKE TO LIFT THE
CALL AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN.
THE MOTION TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN.
PEROT.
CERVANTES.
SO BONTA SIGH.
WITHOUT THAT BILLS OUT.
NEXT ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY FORTY EIGHT.
SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN.
BROUGH.
BRUNO.
COOLEY NO.
COOLEY NO COOPER.
O'DONNELL.
SO THAT THE MEASURE FAILS.
NEXT ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX COOPER.
WELL I BELIEVE HEALTH DUNCAN'S
AND I'M SORRY.
NECK ONE FIVE NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY ONE FRIEDMAN.
THE MOST UP TO.
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THAT MEASURE THE MOTIONS DO
PASS AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ. AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
WROTE.
KRONOS ABUNDANCE.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE
O'DONNELL.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
MIX ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB TWENTY THREE OH FIVE.
SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
BROUGH.
CERVANTES.
THURMOND HAS AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
BUT.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
SO THAT THE MEASURES OUT.
FOR I'M NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
THREE TEN CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS IN MAY
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
BRO.
BROUGH AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER.
AB TWENTY THREE TEN.
NUMBER NINE FIVE MINIMUM NINE.
.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
OKAY THAT MEASURES OUT. A PHONE
NUMBER TEN WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
ONE NEXT ONE IS FIVE NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT.
SECRETARY LIKE CALL THE MISSING
MEMBERS OF SOME MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ. AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
BRO.
NO BRUNO CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
WHERE ON FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT?
O'DONNELL I.
THAT MEASURES OUT THE NEXT ONE
FIVE NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN. SECRETARY LIKE
PAUL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
ALLEN.
FOR.
TWELVE BRUNO CERVANTES.
THURMOND IS I.
THE BILL IS OUT.
NEXT ONE FIVE NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY. SECRETARY
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS THE PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN.
BRO.
CRONO CERVANTES.
THURMOND HAS AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
THE I MEASURES OUT NEXT ONE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT SANTIAGO.
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
MOTIONS TO PASS AND WE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ALLEN.
BRO.
YES.
KRONOS TREMENDOUS.
CERVANTES AYE.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY SIX SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS THE PASSENGER FOR
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN.
THAT MEASURES OUT NATURAL FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B. THIRTY
THIRTY FOUR.
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE ACTIONS DO FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND WE REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ALLEN.
BROUGH.
CRONO.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
I'D
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT MEASURES OUT IN I BELIEVE
WE DID.
TAKE UP SEVENTEEN A B. THIRTY
EIGHTY FOUR WAS THAT MEASURE OUT
OKAY.
NEXT ONE AB.
PHONE NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE SALAS
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
IN THE MOTIONS THE PAST VERY
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE.
RODRIGUEZ AYE ALLEN.
GROW.
THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE.
CERVANTES.
THURMOND HAS AYE COOLEY AYE.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL I.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
AND A BELIEF FIVE NINETEEN WAS
PART OF CONSENT CORRECT.
SO THAT MEMBERS OF THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU.
WELL APART HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
HE WAS.
CORRECT AND WE MAKE. WHICH ONE
BONTA.
OKAY.
WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU